to hello everybody it's Monday
October 2nd fall is here
when is
when is the first day of fall
did that happen
or is it first day of fall is September
oh yeah it's fall you guys oh wow
it's so autumn right now
who's getting that's the pumpkin spice
who's into that
everyone except Dan I think I'm not I'm
not into it and not not from like an
ideological like oh I just don't I just
don't find it to be the best friend I am
very into that okay very much so
how many pumpkin spice lattes have you
had done so far
this season probably like 20 oh [__]
girl you are the queen pumpkin spice
I love that and and Ian how do you feel
about her dependence on the pumpkin
spice
I mean it's a good drink
that's just the cell phone that's just a
still picture of you Ian
he looks good wow yeah he looks handsome
nice to see you today you look good you
look really good yeah thank you today's
episode is sponsored by gamer Subs who
we love sure is
we love them don't we folks they really
are the best all right
you know also I've seen people getting
um people are angry that we didn't do
enough tickets I I I I thought it was a
lot to our live show it is a lot 3 300
it's a lot yeah also like is there even
bigger venues that we could have done
with that short amount of time available
to us well we really want to do one at
the Greek which is about 6 000 but the
Greek is not open during the winter time
because it's an outdoor venue
um and we like the idea of the Dolby
because well it's a little over double
the size of the last venue that we did
which seemed like a sensible jump up and
um also
it's where they do the Oscars it's just
like it's so magical it's so cool so
magical does anybody that hasn't been
there before it is a fantastic theater I
heard they have parking there too which
is crazy plenty of parking that's not
like our last venue that's actually
crazy all the venues we're going to be
standing in the spot where Will Smith
slapped Chris Rock absolutely yeah
that's right we can literally Lee acted
out
we're going to
I would love to play the part of Jada
we should reenact is there any other
Oscar moments that we can reenact the
Brando uh not accepting the academy
that's what I'm saying of setting up a
Native American to uh to scold everybody
yeah okay the Moonlight moment when they
announced the announcing the wrong
winner
yeah and then any steamy steamies ones
we want to uh Herald except fousey
oh
that's not a drum bro that's not a rape
Rim shot that was an iconic moment are
there any other iconic I don't think
anyone gives a [__] about it enough
for there to be anything else Lucy's
only iconic moment yeah
it's still funny after all this time man
it's still funny
uh we got a fun show here it's Monday
you know what I mean
we're gonna start this day off
with all kinds of fun light Goofs we're
not doing anything but light fun Goofs
today right
we've got some
hopefully we've got yeah we've got all
fun like ghost except I mean this
prankster was shot but I consider that a
like this is definitely a goof yeah yeah
this prankster got shot and the jury
acquitted the guys were just shot him
like for pretty much one of the goofiest
shootings of all time
that guy definitely didn't need to be
shoot him and yet the jury still let him
go yeah because everyone's so [__]
sick of these pranksters shoot the son
of a [__] the time between walking up
to the guy and him shooting the
prankster was 20 seconds
right yeah and the way he shot him was
so chill yeah
at least he was chill about it yeah a
little quick scope yep I mean [__] I
guess he he got charged for this uh
using a firearm in a public space right
not shooting a prank YouTube pranks yeah
which is actually a misdemeanor now
it's legal to kill YouTube Pranksters
[Music]
all right [__] it my wrist be careful
all right we're coming in hot oh yeah
we're coming in hot smash that button I
was just saying that um
it's illegal to kill pranksters now
based as a joke based on this and then I
went too far with it right
and that's why I did the button
that was a launching off point for more
inappropriate jokes right and I'll let
you use your imagination run away with
it I goofed up
today uh of course the big news
is that
[Music]
no top hat
it's good towards me yeah no tuck Speedo
but now I I'm so okay
you guys are gonna have to tell me what
to do oh that's such a that's a
beautiful photo wow that looks so nice
there
so right now it's like
I know it's healing so it's gonna look
like that when it's done healing
because right now it's like some of the
white spots in his eyes turn black and
stuff like that yeah mine always gets
super dark like the day after day two
days after that was right after we
finished and it's pulled up again
oh
chill dude
it's just it's beautiful it's perfect
it's just what I wanted I mean it's just
that's my beautiful boy it looks it's
delicious Shredder you know
it looks just like them and it's
it's not easy the picture was really
weird because like he's looking over his
body and there's like a weird tuft of
hair there it's like
but he did it crazy Talent
no shoulders no bow tie not even a bow
tie or talks man
so here so here's what happened
I had it
seal I got the tattoo
Saturday night
it was like five or six hours by the way
and we did not use lidocaine
actually what it didn't hurt that bad it
wasn't that bad it really wasn't in fact
the time went by really fast
nice
you know
so I did it
that's the first question everyone asked
is did it hurt
so interesting
it didn't hurt
you know
um thank you
what a tough guy you are yeah I just
want to let that sit in did anybody want
to not comment on that you're super five
or six hours really really is um here uh
is is that considered a painful spot or
is that supposed to be one of the easier
spots to get easier spots everyone says
it's easy but they're wrong oh the skin
is sensitive I can tell oh okay but it
still didn't hurt because you're just
such a tough guy that being said
everybody says it's an easy spot
but I beg I did I picked it different
okay one of the hardest spots there is
that coffee gets me every time man
um
so afterwards he put this plastic this
really cool plastic thing I don't know
if you guys have seen it it wasn't Saran
Wrap
it's like uh
it's almost like a condom the fat the
the uh texture but they put it over it
he sticks it on and then he pulls the
top layer off and it's like a perfectly
see-through plastic that's
really stuck to it did you bring condoms
I think it would work honestly if you
didn't if you just had that I think it
could work
not recommended though
probably
and um
so I had that on till this morning
when I showered I took it off I washed
it I mean here I'll show it to you guys
standing up the picture obviously looks
a lot better but and right now it's
super greased up
it's greased yep
I love it though it's perfect it really
thank you
it's beautiful
it's just what I wanted
it's bigger than I thought I would get
too which is kind of I like the size of
it you know
so um I took it off this morning I
washed it I put some light moisturizer
on it then when I'm in the car
the sun is on my tattoo and everyone
says Don't Let the Sun hit your tattoo
right so in my car I have a moisturizer
with sunscreen
so I put that over it
and I was like wait can I put sunscreen
on it like obviously I can right but let
me just make sure so I says can I put
can I put sunscreen on my fresh tattoo
no that's the worst thing you can do
it's gonna smudge the ink it's gonna
pull it out it's gonna and I was like oh
[__] so I pulled over
I'm pouring water out of my like
thermos
and then wiping it down with my shirt
so I take all the sunscreen off
hopefully
and then I get to the I get to work
and then
um Olivia gave me a Lido
the nipples the nipple stuff Lena Lynn
lanolin that's what I always use for
mine and it's also what I use for super
chapped lips it's amazing it's for um
breastfeeding mothers it's what they put
on their nipples on their chapped
nipples right it's safe for baby and and
um it's a safer baby relief for Mom
and I walk around I know you swear by
that and I believe you yeah [__] I mean
does your tattoo feel stunning and silky
and fresh definitely feels
it looks yeah yeah that's a glossy arm
it's glossy exactly and so I don't know
then I put I put that all over it and
then I Googled that and they're like
don't put Lionel in on it it will [__]
up the little tear that ink out it will
ruin your tattoo but I don't know if
those people are quacks because a lot of
them seemed kind of quacky
and I don't I don't [__] know dude
every I guess there's just so many damn
opinions on the internet
about how to do it but now I'm all
paranoid did I ruin it
um I mean hopefully not I use it I've
used it in my opinion so unless you used
it super super wrong you should be good
I don't know how I can use it wrong I
just rubbed it on my skin that's what
I'm saying right
uh it says not safe for sure I guess if
you have a it's from sheep did you know
that
that's right sheep from sheep well but
they just sheer sheep they don't kill
them and then they and then they milk it
I don't know about all that like milk
they share the Sheep then they milk the
fur they milk the wool they milk the yes
yes that is where the the moisture comes
from their wool yes they milk the wall
dude
people are just saying just water-based
lotion Aquaphor bro see everybody's
going
at my tattoo artist said just
moisturizer
this is only one ingredient and it's
lanolin
so people are dude there's no don't dry
oh my God people saying Aquaphor lanolin
is an ingredient in Aquaphor
okay everyone's saying Aquaphor everyone
says it's people who say dry and then
people are screaming don't dry don't try
heal
Bolivia has found herself in hot
possibly soon to be boiling water
[Laughter]
no I don't blame it girl I don't blame
you so people are saying Aquaphor now
Aquaphor is mostly petroleum jelly and
I'll tell you this if you look up can I
put petroleum jelly on my new tattoo
it's all like no don't put chili on your
tattoo it'll [__] ruin it
like genuinely what am I supposed to do
I'm literally milking sheep wool doesn't
get more natural than that
no for real people are saying it's fine
let's do a poll but everyone has such
passionate opinions about this
shared from Google can Aquaphor damage
tattoos the truth is Aquaphor with the
petroleum content could potentially harm
your tattoo leading to issues like
ghosting with the petroleum ghosting and
mine is the what is in Aquaphor without
the petroleum no but they say the same
thing about the Lytle they say the same
thing this seems impossible yeah because
they'll answer them at the end of the
day it's an open wound that's the thing
it's like no matter what you put on it
it's you know anything could cause
infection as far as like open wounds and
skin irritations from having kids I I
feel like the the petroleum jelly
products are like miracles for that
stuff
yeah I I always put Vaseline on mine and
then my artists like throughout the
years I came in one time and he's like
yeah don't do that anymore use Aquaphor
and say okay
it's like does anybody actually know is
this one of those things that anyone
really knows just keep it clean and keep
it moisturized and you should be good
keep it secret keep it safe yeah keep it
classy keep it classy nah he was letting
you for fun I have a non-scented
um you know
moisturizer that I put on it at home but
then I [__] up so now I scrubbed it
clean once already because I freaked out
about the sunscreen and now I've and now
I've got this um
this wool milk
that's gonna ghost my tattoo I don't
even know what that means
it doesn't sound good though what's
ghosting mean
yo fading I imagine yo it's my type
tattoo ghosting
two
[Music]
what bro that's not gonna happen this
looks like when you get like a removal
like that's like a laser uh take it off
screen for a sec just in case I don't
know if we have safe search on I don't
want it to show anything
I didn't show anything no you didn't
show anything yeah I know
uh but I don't think that's not gonna
happen
looks like these people had the laser
so anyway
I don't know I'm freaking out because I
love it so much and now I'm freaking out
I'm totally freaking out you'll be fine
but it's starting to scab I guess a
little bit but you know it's pretty
incredible that
you can put ink in the skin and it's
just stays there you would I would think
that like the because we're you know
we're like biological and the skin is
like pretty good at removing [__] from
it how does it stay there you guys
that's crazy
just stays there
stay tuned
yeah but I honestly I'm really happy
Lubriderm fragrance free
small lines tiny bull hit what the [__]
what did I just read
small lines tiny bull hit you're fine
what can this one be called that small
wines tiny bull hit you're fine
put semen on it
loads and loads of calm people are
saying right yeah
oh we didn't do a pull man where's the
pull oh sorry
what did uh Theodore think of it
you like it it's the poll they liked it
yeah they all liked it everyone liked it
how should I word the pole
um okay
well Lino Lynn I don't know how to spell
that slash
Vaseline products I'm going to regroup
them will that destroy my tattoo
uh permanently and irrevocably will
lanolin based products destroy my tattoo
you know what I mean yes or no
everyone knows just yes or no and that
includes like Aquaphor Vaseline every
well yeah Vaseline linoline is gonna
[__] I'm gonna have to carve it out
with a knife because it's just I'm gonna
have to start over
I'm scared wow 30 say yes you guys
that's a lot
19.
I just clicked yes I clicked yes too
because I'm scared yeah me too
wow 80 says no 20 says yes though maybe
that's 20 of the ones that know one in
five people
maybe they know something
[Music]
someone's saying I'm gonna need stem
cells
yo my Tattoo's ghosting what the [__]
oh no no my kids go see him bro that
[__] is scary I told you we should have
put this on it
oh my God I am in hot water it's scary
it looks like lupus but look at me guys
I never thought my life I would get a
tattoo ever
but now I have one love it and it's
pretty big too right like that's pretty
big yeah the first one too especially
and it's it's very visible too actually
which I love when I walk in the mirror
it's like the orientation's perfect and
he looks so good and it just makes me so
it makes me happy to see him like every
time I look in the mirror
really cool
okay
it's a 12 incher should I talk about
like all the other crazy [__] that
people are trying to ruin it for me
no no just no
don't even talk about it nope
should I talk about it nope
nope everybody says nope nope
should I talk about it nope nope
thinking about talking about it yup
but should I nope
but thinking about it yeah
um here's a like here's a perfect image
we got of it right afterwards
the artist had like this uh glare free
setup
so good I loved him it's so good it's
just it's perfect
my mom goes why did he put the circle he
shouldn't have put the circle
I was like what would it make any sense
without the circle
turns into a circle
the thing about old ladies and Tattoos
they just don't [__] with it
did you like the top hat my mom liked
the top hat more than the circle right
should have kept it and then I saw um
another friend of mine today who's a an
older lady and she goes it's so nice but
you should have put it here so that it's
not so it's not visible
it's pretty it's particularly older
Jewish uh women at least that I don't
[__] with tattoos no I mean my
grandmother's told me I'm out of the
will and my parents have told me I'm out
of the world what if I go because of a
tattoo yeah and they're serious they're
so old because the rumor is you can't be
buried in a Jewish cemetery I don't
think it's a rumor although I think they
they lightened up on that that used to
be true but I don't think it's true
anymore
but yeah my parents are pretty uh at
Chad gbt uh yeah I think that that's a I
think that that's an urban legend I
think it used to be true I think it did
well there's that old curb episode his
mom gonna be buried in the Jews I mean I
heard that all growing up I seem to
recall somebody pointing out to me that
that's not well here's a good question
then what about Holocaust Survivors
we're not burying them yeah see that
would be that's a little [__] up
um
and that's part of why I think it's not
true uh can you get buried in a Jewish
cemetery with a tattoo
25 it went up are saying that my tattoo
is going to be ruined you guys while the
Jewish Community might still be divided
over tattoos the prohibition against
bearing tattooed person in Jewish
cemetery is a myth oh oh oh I'm gonna go
get one tonight
hell yeah dude get one of Shredder maybe
there are like certain communities that
don't like it and so forbid is it is it
against the uh Jewish faith to to tattoo
I thought there was like a rule about it
about like desecrating your body or some
[__] maybe it has to do with the
Holocaust Survivors nothing goes before
that
yo can you imagine to like listen bro I
know you've been through some [__] but
you're tattooed
um yeah it's generally considered
against uh Jewish law mentioned in the
Torah you shall not make any cuts on
your body for the dead or tattoo
yourselves I am the Lord
[__] had to end it with I am the Lord
too care I am the Lord yeah no tattoos I
am the Lord
yeah I gotta start when I get when I
tell people to do that I'm gonna end
like I'm the Lord uh Lena can you get me
a coffee I am the Lord
you got it Lord thank you I already I
already have one thank you oh somebody
uh in the chat pointed out if you get a
swastika tattoo they might have an issue
with that that is a very that's listed
one it's All or Nothing Dad it's one or
not tough crowd tough crowd
Arabs are the same way they don't like
tattoos we were at a barbecue one
Selena's mom just looked over at me and
she goes you know there's a place down
the street that opened up tattoo removal
like no one was talking about it and
I've had the tattoos forever I was like
oh thank you
it's good to know
um you're such a bad boy though do you
like bad boys Lena because he is kind of
a bad boy
he's got the Mustang he's got the tats
I mean it's not what I was going for but
it's
it's cool
oh you butt boy that's nice she thinks
you're cool
I think you're cool too thank you oh no
I just mean like that wasn't my I don't
have a specific type yeah right looking
for that you weren't looking for the bad
boy creaser that came to you just
happened to find one he just cruised up
in that Mustang and said okay get in get
in loser
we're going to the tattoo shop we're
going to get a boosted board
okay are you guys sure I shouldn't talk
about it
nope
oh wait
hold on not sure no about oh did we not
see this did I not show this on Friday
yeah Productions got my mom man again so
I saw my mom this weekend and she's like
okay here's my phone please block
Productions and follow you and I was
like I think you already did we checked
so I get on her phone so she's not
following me
and she's following Productions
and so I helped her I blocked
Productions apologies you know it's not
personal it's just for my mother's
well-being
and now she does follow me the real h3h3
Productions
he actually did uh do something he
posted I'm trying to find out on Reddit
where he said uh this is my mom now or
something yeah because she followed him
yeah and that confused the hell out of
me because I just I didn't understand
what was going on
Productions get your get your mom called
like donaton or something
get a Bizarro mom
the other weird thing is like I swear
that the I can see the plastic marks
I'm assuming those will go away yeah
yeah
so there it is guys I'm a cool dude I
did it for five six hours you didn't
even hurt I sat there the time went by
so fast bro and straight up I was like
I'm ready for more bro
let's go longer dude and it's one of the
hardest spots too I don't know if I
mentioned that yeah so sensitive I think
you did touch your skin there tell me
how soft and sensitive is it wow it
hurts just now yeah careful don't touch
too hard
seniors makes me want to touch up mine
because I miss when mine were that dark
mine definitely lightened up over the
years so can you get it like touched up
what's the deal oh yeah definitely yeah
I have a temporary Lego tat that's what
you need dude
there's some new oh there's some cool
new LEGOs coming out right
um
some cool new blocks yeah they're hooked
up yeah have you heard about any there's
like a new movie franchise coming to the
from Bricktown oh is there that's pretty
cool you don't know you don't know about
this I that's the new stuff is not
really like my world I like that the
like the Star Wars and the the Oh I
thought your pulse was on your fingers
on the pole so like the Ninjago [__]
like that's really not one oh Teddy
loves Ninjago what's Ninjago what the
[__] you guys did it's a it's a Lego
ninja show for kids it's not for kids
this is for the general public you're
right you're right right you're right
it's pretty cool but the the Ninjago's
fire Zach you should try one it's
dragons
yeah you know don't hate it I thought
you followed all the latest drops I'm
always here I don't know what Ethan is
talking about to be completely honest
yeah I thought hold on let me see new
Lego
uh uh coming soon that's all I'm gonna
type
yo there's a Mario one coming soon the
plant that looks that's actually cool
yeah
have you got that one it was not out yet
I think it comes out in November you're
gonna get that one probably
that's sick
yo that one's 18 plus that's One's Gonna
Be Crazy to do 18 plus I'll Whip that
out where an hour what does the plant do
it's just it's just super hard to put
together bro it's like oh oh oh okay I
practically need a degree
fire
Lego sponsor us man dude that's a dream
please oh what's maybe oh it's a Marvel
stuff was this what I was thinking of
Jay's breakfast
coded oh you know about Jay of course me
and Ian always uh talk about them uh-huh
yo maybe we could connect you here he is
Jay if you're out there connect with my
bro man yeah he's he's alive for follow
he's a Lego head
yeah
oh I see yeah this guy's in deep huh
that's fire exact time he has all of
them I had those well you have all those
are rare when I was a kid I had one of
those little space men I didn't have the
whole color set
all right so Moving on but
Productions is now sending me threats
oh boy he says this is a DM who do you
send this to I mean I've been in contact
with him just a fellow he said this to
you love yeah he said I will not stop
until the Klein family believes I'm one
of their own until Theodore and Brucie
call me their father so the crew
believes I am their leader so the
audience calls me the one and only host
of the H3 podcast one day Ethan will get
on his hands and knees and beg for his
showback and there producatons will
stand satire's a lesson parody is a game
laughs
I am the Lord wow
okay there's an interesting theory that
producatons is coming from inside the
house
so does anyone
I don't know anything about that
'd be a high level game to play one of
y'all was pretty crazy I have no way of
proving pretty why I've been in contact
with him since like 2020. that'd be a
long bone yeah it was pretty sauce love
well uh
when I have social media guy well I've
been in contact with almost all the
parity accounts and stuff like that
because yeah yeah where I came from they
have a brother they have a Facebook
group together you're the one that made
it yeah look I'm just saying I'm not
accusing you of anything I'm just I
wouldn't put it past you right of course
but why is he so why is he so serious
about this he goes
satire is a lesson parody is a game yeah
like what I mean Productions what's
happening man
he's crazy bro I mean
who is he he always sends me screenshots
of when people uh follow him it's like
oh I'm gonna troll them so hard what the
[__] like when Stevo followed him
I literally can't do anything about it I
don't know how to help people
if you're over the age of like 45 you're
[__] yeah for sure you're just gonna
get productoned
see a lot of speculation that it's Ian
that's the only I was suspecting it
might be Ian but
oh oh look at that look at that [__]
in Grand one more time Ian that's ah
it's Ian for sure man can't help it you
can't help but anyone did that
Ian is funny enough to do this but I
think he might be too lazy to do it and
I don't mean that as an insult like I'm
lazy when I'm not working in I'm very
lazy right I think you're a good worker
so that's not what I mean by this up
right now is that an accurate
characterization do you think
uh you don't even you could you're not
even gonna talk now please stand up at
least play me a sound bite and please
stand up
Jesus he's just not wearing pants
God damn I can't even you don't want to
even talk anymore okay
I like legs and uh
no brother
that's all you have to say all right
[Laughter]
anyway thank you to the artist I'm very
happy I'm very very happy with it super
cool I'm a tattoo guy now guys I would
do another one honestly because it just
wasn't that bad
I don't know though because I feel like
I only would want to do it if it was
something
I'm not really into like the art aspect
of it more so just like the sentimental
value of it I don't know
like I respect that y'all
like putting art on your bodies that's
cool
I'm not sure if that's my thing though
majority of mine are sentimental as well
really yeah can you explain them to me
um I feel like I don't like explaining I
feel like it's cheesy but like
I will explain one of them this one is a
plane that's the plane my uncle piloted
World War II so that's what my uncle
passed away I got that one oh wait which
side hold on which side did he fight for
uh for us okay good what kind of plan is
it uh I forget I had it written down has
he been living in Canada for the past 70
years he's dead
yo your gramps is a is a World War II uh
fighter pilot
my my uncle is actually your uncle my my
uh notorious cousin Tim his father yeah
oh wow he's a [__] cool he's a vet
man my grandpa was uh also in the Air
Force he wasn't a fire pilot though he
was on one of the bombers
my grandpa too uh I mean he's passed now
but he was in like
he used to man the gun on the bottom of
the ship you know because you had to
like manually frame it damn that's like
the most dangerous right The Balter is
that what you're talking about the
balturer yeah that is the the highest
death rate of any of the positions and
he had to parachute out a few times
absolutely not yeah my uh my grandpa was
uh Bombardier he was the one actually
dropping the bombs
those guys are heroes man can you
imagine that stuff's so scary that's
like real yeah the Nazis were real bad
guys you know
they were the real bad guys yeah stop
dissing the Nazis all the time bro stop
bro
Gordon I don't get you
um it is uh 33 minutes by the way if we
want to do our what is this we got more
producton threats oh maybe double you
know what
oh
starting to feel like the real Ethan
Klein he said
there's no competition in my way I can
feel the power of the fupa flowing
through me perhaps I am the real Ethan
Klein
you're not man you're not just stop
you're freaking me out dude your message
this was when you were bad that he was
like blowing up or was he doing bomb
threats and [__] bro and he always takes
it too far
he always takes it to the to the worst
spot it was going really hard with it
like straight up like threatening people
it's not me you guys
I was like bro you're gonna give us in
trouble or something I I got for
talkatons you gotta chill brother
Adam
um all right so let's thank our yeah
this is dude get out of my [__] life
man look at this
producatons
act like you own the place one of the
best films of the decade
yo get out anyway
movie reference
thank you
uh shut up gamer Subs man I love it
now the reviews are in everybody is
raving raving about Sigma brain
it actually looks like that in real life
it's transparent yeah it's so sick I
killed the green screen
and so here's what I'm reading
people say no I don't like spicy
and I didn't expect to like it
but I got it to support the show they
say
and then they says it's not spicy it's
amazing
it's just a little tickle it's not spicy
it's just a little bit of a Competitive
Edge you know what I mean it's just a
little tickle
the flavor is incredible
it supports your mind during gaming
you're gonna be the Ultimate Gamer
correct and also you're gonna do
everything else really good hydrating
it's fortified with vitamins and
minerals it's got caffeine in it to keep
you alert you can get non-caffeine too
and it's the best [__] flavor dude
let's look at reviews
the reviews are pouring in you guys
they're in and these are all legitimate
right I mean this is this is just
I don't think you can review it it's
it's verified purchases only yep look at
that is that a perfect five that's a
perfect five it's not even like a sliver
missing huh it might even be more than
five and they don't have the ability to
display that just like on Wiki feet when
you have like a seven out of five yeah
experience the Bold you've done an H3
Sigma brain a balance between zesty lime
and a gradual controlled Heat this
unique Elixir awakens your senses and
sharpens your mind offering refreshing
yet daring twist elevate your taste
Journey with H3 Sigma brand and embrace
a new realm of flavor and focus that's
good coffee yeah I agree with that
um cheers my dudes
cheers my dude
it really is the best flavor
you guys love it I do yeah definitely
but with more enthusiasm it is
the best you guys see what I'm saying
man
but like you used to be doing mango Dan
that's out the window right you dumb uh
it wasn't a mango I was uh I was a uh
the blue rasp boy blue Razz is out
converted and love what you were doing I
was the manga ball and you're out yeah
I'm out on the yeah
it's all Sigma I'm very proud actually
of how good it came out it's so good I
love the art so much too it's the
official like H3 Nate really matters
taste is obviously a little bit more
important than the label you know but
it's cool we also we we all came
together to formulate this flavor uh
it's true we really did Tinker with the
with the flavor and and we were in the
laboratory pillow was perfect and we
didn't come out until it was perfect
yeah
um cheers my dude dude awesome yeah it
doesn't use sugar At All by the way so
if you're on like if you're trying to
get off sodas or sweet drinks or if you
don't drink sugar which I don't
recommend I don't ever drink sugar
to me that's just like the biggest
waste of calories yeah because it's like
what you're gonna drink a sugar drink
and then that's 200 calories
doesn't fill you at all
so it doesn't use sugar and it tastes
amazing you know
let's see
yada yada use code H3 for 10 off your
order
right go to gamersups.gg and use the
code H3 for 10 off your order
you know what I'm saying
cheers my dude right
that's
gamersups.gg use the code H3 for 10 off
your order and join the sigma brain
nation and step up that brain yep to a
sigma level
thank you join brains
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this hold on they want it
um
that air
okay
thank you
yo look at that five stars though okay
we already we moved on
thank you
uh what else we got
um
[Music]
oh Alex Jones got choked out can I show
this
it didn't get a
I mean he's fine he just got choked out
it's very odd it's a very odd video very
strange video also I isolated some
noises from it after we play the video
if you want me to but that's worth it
yeah but it you know
very odd this is what this is what these
Alpha dudes are doing they're just choke
they're taking Alpha Brain they're
choking each other out it's like
I mean what what kind of idea of fun is
this
El Segundo podcast wherever that is
here
on band.video yeah my favorite website
wide shot
and this guy goes way too hard on him I
just gonna I'm gonna lights out take a
little snooze
do I put this up though we're not fools
he says stop
and now he's
dead he killed him
why would you do that that's not that's
not a fun thing to do
he's like a monster oh my God
he's an actual demon he's an ogre who
wakes up like that he's like an actual
ogre look at it
and Alex Jones strikes me as a dude who
who has to sleep with like a
a CPAP machine with like a mask and a
defibrillator sure you know if you wake
him up he's he yells as he wakes he's
like
so I guess my point is I don't think
this is the smartest idea
yeah don't do this at home
I'm anti-choking out your friends for
fun for the record
what the [__]
but I understand what I just do
what I was doing
he lost his memory I would actually pass
out yeah
huh yeah ah I did pass out
see I don't I'm not looking to do that
it's also not that funny either it's
kind of weird like what's wrong with
these guys man
how did these go how do we propose these
guys get it out
do they go do we just give them some
Spears and send them to the Jungle to
just like kill raw beef
it looks like Alex needs exorcism I
don't know that's true
I just don't know what to do with all
these these Alpha bros man well they're
choking themselves out so maybe we don't
have to worry about it much longer
problem take care of yourself it's true
yeah okay so shout out Alex Jones he's a
real man
he's a real I bet he wouldn't do a
tattoo in the most sensitive spot for
five or six hours
he couldn't handle it
I don't know not many could frankly not
many could
are you guys proud of me though at least
I was pretty scared to get it yeah
definitely
I was super nervous when we first
started
I was so curious to see yeah how you
would do but you listed right away you
handled it no problem it just it was
hurt a lot less than I expect I expected
to really [__] hurt man I I mainly
went to one guy I've only got one of my
tattoos from someone else and I did
notice that the second guy was like so
much more painful ugh because sometimes
artists will like stop stop to take a
little break in between which is what I
think is proper but the other guy I went
to was actually the owner of the shop
did not stop the whole time this guy
didn't stop only to get more ink
it was just continuing yeah yeah it was
just continuous one tiny little needle
mm-hmm
but he was saying sometimes if you if
you're doing a bolder color or going
deeper to get like a more bold color
then it hurts more
yeah the one I got with the other guy
was a lot of shading too so
but then like when he got up here near
the crease then it started to hurt a lot
more my crease oh my God especially like
when your adrenaline starts to run out I
don't know if you experienced that where
it felt more painful towards the end
really yeah but like at the crease right
there that [__] kill yeah the crease
is that that was painful the crease
feels like you're getting electrocuted
what's the deal with the crease it's
like super thin skin I guess or nerves
nerves I don't know yeah come on crease
in my uh the elbow too I remember that
elbow was super painful oh like on the
point of your elbow
around here and here was like it felt
like someone saw my armor yeah wow that
didn't sound good at all yeah no I can't
that just that would be right on your
bone
crazy
um
he told me the most painful spot in his
opinion
and his experience was behind the knee
the soft part you know what I mean there
the crease of the leg Yeah the crease of
the leg he said was crazy devastating
place I bet yeah
he was also telling me he just did a tap
for somebody on their [__] eyelids I
was like whoa
that's crazy but I've seen to eyelid
tasks but it just seems like really
intense it's running your [__]
eyeball okay Ethan how does it not go in
your eyeball because it's like
your eyelids are very thin
as everybody knows as we all have
eyelids okay Ethan people have tattooed
their eyes before right that will vary
and that's just [__] nuts yeah are
you awake for that
I don't know there's no way how could
you keep your eye open if someone's jams
up
a needle into it think about that
that's badass though I I heard the Eye
Tattoo is second most painful to this
spot right here for sure okay
uh James Charles go to the chiropractor
great it's a combination of my two
favorite things
fantastic oh let's see what happens well
if there is one person I would send to
the chiropractor would be James
I'd be like hey put some extra attention
on his neck if you know what I mean all
right oh my God
what just adjust his net
oh my god do one of those ones where
it's like Hey listen I want you to put a
little extra attention on his neck
sometimes accidents happen at the
chiropractor
oh sometimes like you adjust it a little
too far
let's see
today I'm gonna get cracked this is my
first time ever today I'm gonna get
cracked I just took my x-rays apparently
my body is not in the best of shape and
we're gonna fix that usually nothing on
my mind and we're gonna fix that watch
I'm gonna prove to you guys right now
what a quack this guy is okay watch this
I hope so the first thing I'll say about
chiropractors they all want to be like
not all but a lot of them are like tick
talkers like they they want to be like
celebrities and a real Doctor Who's
concerned with your health and and
treatment is not they're not trying to
be like on camera talents just weird
because it's serious it's serious work
medicine this is not a serious guy
like here here's another thing if you're
a serious doctor you don't make this
face look at his face you don't make
that face when you're creating someone
you don't look surprised and a little
scared
okay you know what to expect because
it's science now look at that face no
oops that's not a real medical treatment
that's just a dude who's turning your
head and open for the best
look at his face this one's gonna go a
little bit like like I'm sorry that's
your [__] whoa dude did you hear
that crack the doctor's like that that
was a big crack you guys
that's not real medicine
hell no
better oh my God
look at him oops he sounds so much like
Mickey Mouse it's crazy
literally
whoa that was good
oh oh
what oh
what are you talking about
that yeah that's crazy
so bad you do better
go ahead I'm waiting
did it do it again
I think I win
pretty good I don't know
whatever I put my heart into it you're
right you're right James wins though as
Mickey he takes the he takes the cake yo
my favorite doctor is the one that looks
surprised and slightly worried when they
treat me that's my favorite man
he just laughs because it's so absurd
look at him he can't even see his face
he's just like Yo dude that one was
crazy
look at him he's doing a soy face over
his back
yo that was crazy you guys did you hear
that
[Music]
bro
oh you said you weren't gonna crack holy
[__] oh my god wow sister snapped
included
I'm not gonna be able to hear that now I
can't get over what boy
wait do it again I'm right here
thank you my dad used to do it I was
growing up you were kind of getting in
there
take that back whoa that's like demon
duck I don't know dude I want to go to a
sharper and have them crack my back and
then just pretend to die oh
and to the incinerator I would love to
see their reaction imagine having that
on camera that'd be fun as [__] [__]
[__]
dude I'm sorry this profession is a
[__] joke
I'm pretty sure that I could take a few
online courses practice with some
friends and then do what they do
these just crap they they do all the
same cracks too they go crack the hip
crap the neck crack the fingers I can
crack fingers you just pull it what's
the [__] imagine it's a joke the only
difference is they're more confident
because usually when you do that you're
like I don't want to hurt you and
they're like I don't care if I hurt you
there's a I was I saw one pop up on
YouTube It's called The Ring Dinger
where they like put your hips in like a
Contraption and they put a towel around
your neck and then they just pull your
head and it's supposed to crack your
spine let's let's pull it
feels so good
I found the ring I found the ring Dinger
compilation but this looks like
something else maybe I want to say thank
you to la love route for the 20 gifted
thank you so much that's very sweet of
you thank you oh wait are we doing the
the
are we doing the the members drive this
week and we'll start playing with on
Friday oh we should talk about it so
this Friday we're gonna do the members
Drive which apparently is just going to
be me getting drunk and trying to
explain things
which everybody had a lot of fun with
last time
um and
other things
we haven't put much thought into it yet
it's gonna be fine yeah it's gonna be
fun it's gonna be fun I'm sure of it
how do you feel I feel good
nice meeting you yeah you too
[Music]
yeah sorry not serious
sorry not beautiful
I watch Cairo compilations
I know I've never said that but I watch
Cairo compilations well I I always watch
them I'm fascinated by it it looks like
it feels so good I crack my neck all the
time though so are you a chiropractor
you believe in that I don't think I
believe in it I just know that when I
crack my neck I like it
there you don't have to pay someone to
do it and the likelihood that you'll
sever your head is very low mm-hmm
look at this guy
he's like I'm gonna try to dislodge your
spine from your body
because when is it a towel
a towel wrapped around someone's neck as
a medical tool
like I'm sorry bro
anybody can do that it's just a matter
of like being confident and sadistic
enough to pull that hard all he's doing
is pulling his [__] head away from
his body that's very strong okay what's
he doing that's so Secret
oh
oh [__] oh my gosh she wasn't ready for
it
she like broke her yaw yeah this lady's
this is the ring Dinger huh give her the
old ring dinger
[Laughter]
it doesn't matter it didn't work he's
got amnesia from that [__] Bro
they're hitting that Mitch McConnell
ring
[Music]
oh [__]
looks like it feels really good
oh whoa that one sounded good
[Music]
then he has to like check the reflexes
to make it they can feel their legs
after a for sure does like a niece yeah
yeah exactly he's like [__] he goes I'll
be right back the knees aren't working
the knees aren't kicking what do I do
keep incredibly happened
at the Dark Souls font did it really oh
yeah you died it did it did no shot let
me see
oh it's good with the uh oh that was it
placement music
what you're seeing here is the work of a
serial killer right sure maybe the most
prolific serial killer of our time
and you know what's scary the good ones
we only catch the bad ones
because if they're smart and they're
good they never get caught oh yeah
oh and the ring Dinger here he knows
what I'm saying Jeffrey dahmers
it doesn't matter if die now or in 10
years from now he knows it was this yeah
these are his victims
oh my God they paid him to do this
[Music]
I used to watch murder porn
uh this one is [__] awesome man look
at this [__]
I I guess I'm assuming this is like a
Ron Burgundy situation
where she got teleprompted but man it's
so funny it's like so out of pocket
here
suicide is always there as an option but
it's never the right solution to the
problem and if you hit your Breaking
Point instead just taking your life do
something one step short of it quit your
job and move to China
don't quit your job there are resources
available she says if she what was she
going okay so what she was saying or
reading was like if you are suicidal
just stop one
blip short of killing yourself quit your
job and move to China and become a rice
picker
that's what I thought too but I think
she realized she's being trolled and
then try to get back on the rails that's
the only explanation I have always there
as an option but it's never the right
solution to the problem she says it's
always there as an option never forget
it's always an option what is she
reading what demon put this together
don't forget
that is always an option he said that
there's someone on the CCP working in
the back rooms they were trying to like
recuse me yeah we need my rice figures
we need cheap labor yeah
there's one thing we don't have enough
of it's people in China right right well
you know things are you know listen
inflation hits China too man I'm just
I'm so baffled by this clip like what
it's like somebody put together the most
[__] up thing you can say during
Suicide Prevention month and got her to
say it
it's always there as an option
but it's never the right solution to the
problem and if you hit your Breaking
Point instead just taking your life
get short of it quick you quit your job
and move to China
some rice or don't quit your job there
are resources available talk to your
loved one and that is crazy
oh that's crazy I guess someone was
quitting or something that's pretty
demonic though
yeah she got Ron Bergen dude
yeah it does okay I found something
about it
Kentucky news anchor said she was
floored and confused when during a
recent broadcast her teleprompter script
included jokes about suicide that she
unwittingly read on air in a thread on X
formerly Twitter here here's the thread
she issued a statement yeah she said
uh hi this post may be long oh god let's
see let's see well let's dip our toes
okay
uh hi this post may be long but uh to me
it's important so I hope you can take
the time to read something horrible
happened on our newscast Wave 3 news at
3 P.M on September 22nd when I was
anchoring first I want to personally
apologize for those who were hurt
Disturbed dot dot
where's the thread
she erased it it was just what she
probably posted another tweet like a
boom Oh my God she doesn't know how to
put a thread together I get it okay I
thought I misspoke or someone missed the
words or there's a typo in the first
sentence so confused my brain was stuck
okay yeah so she got trolled there she
got trolled definitely
I want to know who's that good person
sorry Dan Ethan I've been really
enjoying the socialism capitalism
democracy conversations hey there's one
to y'all
that think you can't have civil
disagreements touch grass okay I agree I
mean I agree I think we ran into the
ground for now though I could talk about
it more but I don't think the world is
ready yeah not ready for this for this
high level
in charge I'll come back stronger though
more ready more prepared smarter faster
more capitalist than ever wait a minute
we just got a crazy update one of the
mods just sent me this was a super chat
that we missed
20 euros don't know if you remember me
but I called in the third after dark
episode to tell about my broken wiener
I'm flying from libsen to LA to see you
guys
do you remember that I remember that I
hope it means for the live show yeah for
the live show
he's outside right now wait he broke his
dick yeah do you remember similar to a b
story yeah uh kind of yeah I do vaguely
remember I mean God that was a long time
ago yeah it was uh I believe if I
remember it was the first time sleeping
with someone as well and oh man
accident yeah crosswords you guys could
dab I remember he called in and it was a
great call all right well we look
forward to seeing you you know if you
want to prove the Nick's doing good yeah
if you've seen one of us just whip out
your dick to prove it to you
just kidding don't do that that's don't
do that that's a horrible thing to do no
you'll be escorted out that's a crime
you'll be arrested you will be arrested
I did not put my dick anywhere near my
dog I didn't ask Jordan in fact
uh okay well I look forward to seeing
you buddy that's great to hear it thank
you love that
if we sell out the Greek
would that that's gonna be like one of
the biggest live podcasts ever what who
does bigger podcast live podcasts than
that
nobody a note yeah no I'm genuinely
curious I don't know like I don't think
it's always a friend it's always sunny
podcasts they do uh like Live Events
like I know they they sold out a few
theaters as well
oh we need to find out because I need to
flex if that's the case the street the
steam the Streamys need to find out
about this immediately
also we're going to have to present the
award eventually for
most attendees at a live podcast
yes and not to toot our own horn but if
it's me any more Awards you know
I need to be acknowledged with Awards
more
thank you
that's right she is
Mrs
steamies
she is beautiful
YouTube's sexiest night starring
Ethan Klein
other guests unannounced yet the crew
with H3 podcast
comedy by Jimmy Lee
[Applause]
live performance by rectangular guy
[__] we gotta get rectangular guy out
there for that oh we got the timestamp
here let's let's take a walk through
Memory Lane here about the the broken
dick and it's snapped is that right
yeah it was really really weird so uh
basically I was meeting this guy and you
know I was like uh you know I was having
sex with him and I like someone told me
about this position that is called
bumper cars that's right
yeah I forgot about the bumper cars
man that's a don't do the bumper card
I don't know tell me about it
it was fairly graphic yeah
times have changed my friends
the steamies is a family event people
shout out to my family Ethan a b cam Dan
hila Ian Lena Olivia Sam Zach
man that was when I stopped being a
hater ass [__] and we were friends with
Ninja for like a week
yeah that was a good time
it was a nice wig
okay so this is pretty good now Linda
yakarino I'm gonna call her yuck Arena
baby so he hired this lady to be the CEO
of X it's clear to me that she's just
some really weird puppet Elon simp like
really weird she did a um a talk at Vox
Medias
recent event
and people asked her a few questions I
mean and and she had trouble answering
them
um it was quite Illuminating in fact but
but about elon's uh influence on X let's
say so listen
I want to go back to your uh he runs
product
uh he runs technology he leads a team of
exceptionally talented engineers
and who's kidding who
I don't care what the structure is at
meta but who wouldn't want
Elon Musk sitting by their side running
product
of hands people are raising their hands
and frankly from all accounts that
sounds like the worst case scenario
yeah super annoying yeah
but the the smugness that she's like
just [__] riding that [__] man she's
trying to have his 15th baby or
something
I'll probably be announced at some point
I there may be a few show of hands to
get the cute Chuckles you're getting but
I would say the percentages in this room
are about 99 percent
no shot I would say no to that and one
percent of
maybe personal opinion so well I mean
he's the richest man in the world I mean
that's all there's an asset in that too
not just because he's like smart and can
help you code
so there's that that was just one clip
there's a whole bunch of them
uh she won't this is great so Elon Musk
apparently said that X isn't going to be
free anymore
he said that there'll be a charge for
everybody
which would be fun I would love to see
that man I don't X wouldn't last the
week I don't think
but here she is uh asking her this very
straightforward question Elon Musk just
announced a new monthly fee for users
yep and my question for you is do you
want to start charging all users of X as
he said and how many users do you think
you will lose as a result
can you repeat Elon Musk announced
you're moving I'm sorry you heard every
damn word of that she assuming she even
acknowledged while she was talking she's
like uh-huh all the way yeah
awesome an entirely subscription-based
service yeah nothing free on about using
X
yeah nothing free on about using X
do you say we were moving to it
specifically or is thinking about it he
said that's the plan yeah so because
smoke is no he goes no I don't think
that's smug
I kind of get smugness too yeah she's
like oh well you don't know what's
really happening no I I sense annoyance
because she is constantly being undercut
by this [__] and this is the first
time that she's hearing about this
that's for sure I think it's the first
time she's hearing about it too which is
another thing that Elon Musk notoriously
does according to his programmers that
he'll like make announcements in the
press that they have never heard about
and have never started right
clearer is thinking about it he said
that's the plan yeah so yeah to
de-consult you before he announced that
we talk about everything
Elon Musk oh God who wouldn't want Elon
Musk right working side by side
comfortable
she's so overcompensating we talk about
everything
uh another good one asked uh about X's
declining usage oh no
is that true by the way I don't know
it is according to her she basically
confirmed uh what people are speculating
that uh there is a decline in usage
okay but it wasn't confirmed is this a
photo yeah it's just a photo to show
that on her oh she showed her okay I see
what's happening yeah she has like
Facebook and other platforms on there
but she this is her home page
X isn't on it Instagram's on there
Instagram you have Instagram Facebook
he's a Zuckerberg
we love Zuck how the [__] I mean she's
Boomer as hell she's on Facebook she's
not on x
there it is wow
fantastic huh what a [__]
good for you lady you got a killer job
you're gonna be all right we're all
rooting for you
also uh this weekend Elon took the
ugliest photo of anyone ever it's like a
straight to a
a meme a cartoon meme straight away I
mean look at the soy Happening Here
this is a soy Avatar
he's got the he's got the pilgrim-esque
neckbeard
he's got the weird hunched over jawline
and mouth
he's got the back the cowboy hat which
is backwards
oh this [__] kills me every time I saw
some really funny illustrations already
on that brutal
uh at least the uh the soy Jack version
of it is is in this if you scroll down
oh good yeah yeah
that's awesome what is with that beard
brother
ah damn
yeah so that was fun yeah appreciate
that happening
he was down on the border doing some
kind of weird
uh immigration control thing
really weird
uh he was kind of awkwardly Milling
around talking to some Congress people
and some border patrol agents he's
getting more political like I know he's
been trying but he's getting more
political like what's he planning uh
uh well I mean
I doubt that he would run for anything
he's not eligible to be president and
why the hell would he want to be like a
senator or something yeah that would be
way way or maybe a gov yeah governor
governor governor of Texas watch out
Abbott
yeah I don't know I really don't know
uh more than anything I think he's uh
the he's just desperate to get people
using his apps video features because
that was sort of like the point of this
was uh to promote citizen Journal
journalism on uh on Twitter and get
people but uh the issue is it is it it
crashed several times again like every
time that he goes live because it's
because he has so many followers anytime
he goes live he gets a [__] ton of
viewers and the servers can't handle it
and it starts crashing uh he went to the
let's see
he went to the uh the border to talk
about people who are breaking the law
and claim there would be a collapse in
Social Services if the country didn't
act to curb illegal immigrants New York
City is already ready to buckle under
the load HE further added that the US
military needs to get involved and the
tanks should be on the border and open
fire on immigrants
with giant tank rounds
that's a joke but there are people that
say bring the military to the border
which is yeah everything everybody in
the GOP debate last week said that let's
get the tanks literally that's the
Border that's just the platform now
let's go to war with Mexico let's do it
no not Mexico just immigrants just
defenseless
desperate they were saying they want to
go into Mexico though and do what to
deal with like the cartels and stuff oh
okay well the cartel stuff is
yeah it's still sending a military into
your neighbor's country is kind of well
if it's in collaboration with the
Mexican Government though yeah which it
would be
I'm pretty sure you need permission
yeah no of course yeah you need
permission you don't think the Mexican
Government will want to get rid of the
cartels uh it's complicated
let's get them Let's do let's just shoot
anyone that moves man we'll get them all
eventually
if we can kill a million people in Iraq
we can sure damn kill a million people
in Mexico no problem
you know
thank you
in other news
liver King's been riding my nuts
it's funny because we were just
wondering
um what's he been up to
and he's first let's see he first text
missed texted me this let's see
Brian liver King AKA never talk about my
wife in this context you're right I do
apologize for that
or was this on uh
this was on Instagram let me pull it up
where's liver there it is whatever
so he goes
Primal Ethan
oh here I'll pull it up I've got it
bro you already called me sub Primal you
know we're not on the same wavelength
right oh no this is just the PDF okay so
let me read the DM
liver says
Primal Ethan
liver King here inviting you to the
Barbarian Crucible
because our modern day men are
submissive and weak
I would know because I was one of them
I'm like bro
I'm not one of these people
[Music]
then I did what any self-respecting lion
would do and weaponize the pain into a
process I created this show I created
this to show young men how to [__]
strive plus your audience would kill to
see you suffer like this
you can make fun of the Alfred archetype
along the way that's a custom line yeah
so you think he wrote this just for me
or he just added a little custom line
there I thought he wrote it at the very
least it was edited yeah
yeah so I'm inviting Giants across
categories to bleed through the
Barbarian Crucible it's by invite only
and it's on my dime it better [__] me
I'd like to send you all the details if
you're man enough to accept
bro I'm not eight
you [__] or a man he continues trust me
you're going to want to see more or else
you'll have to live with the regret
what's your email and I was at first I
was like whatever Brian but then I was
like [__] I want to see that PDF
actually so I said hell yeah brother
here's my email
and I got the email
here's The Crucible
I don't know what this [__] is
this is my personal invite from liver
the liver King challenge which by the
way
is not actually that personal as you'll
see in the next link but
this one
no I you'll see what I mean um as we go
on Barbarian crucible why our modern day
men are hurting the most man they're
weak subprimal and submissive I would
know because that I was one of them
I weaponized the pain into a process the
Barbarian isn't this what he dm'd you
it's Sim it's very similar
[Laughter]
I want to spread this message and share
a path for young primals to [__]
strive man here I am wandering through
the desert with weights attached to me
yeah just like my ancestors which which
as you know is a great use of our
limited time on this Earth yes
I get working out but what is this man
you're literally like this is like a
Greek tragedy Parable it's like the guy
who keeps pushing the rock uphill
forever that's you man you don't have
and you don't have to be that
foreign
Let's see we got the exclusive invite
guys
availability is changing daily as others
accept the Barbarian Crucible
take massive [__] action
and hit reply within two hours or else
there will be consequences
like what again Brian I'm 38.
and what is this like boomerass chain
email thing if you do not forward this
to 10 people you will die within seven
days
oh my God Brian you're such a [__]
goofball you have like that mentality of
an eight-year-old literally man like
your kids might be more mature
what the Barbarian Crucible is composed
of nine stages
calling upon the alpha masculine
tactical virtues across history
strength
courage Mastery honor and loyalty
tactical virtuous what is a tactical
virtue Mastery how is that a Virgo
that's like a skill level right I mean
Mastery is not a virtue uh-huh
here he is after a big long workout man
look at though he's sitting boy because
he's worked real hard taking a [__] on
his estate on his massive estate
welcome to the way of the Barbarian he
has not said anything yet 126 ways to be
a [__] man 126 ways to take whatever
the [__] you want in life
uh well there's some limitations on that
right a couple we need consent
uh to always stack the deck Dominate and
win at life bro you haven't told me
anything what is this
outcome a more complete Beast you the
very in Crucible is a YouTube series
featuring YouTube Giants man who's going
to agree to do this
it's calling you fat
huh
YouTube Giants oh I don't think he meant
it like that
you know but maybe
or maybe just like a camp
it's it's just space camp or Alphas it
really is
uh it's strikingly compelling and Primal
AF content to disseminate on our
respective platforms to spread the
message give young primals a path to
dominate here's a quote regret is the
regret is the haunting echo of choices
unmade and opportunities untaken a
reminder that the past is an eternal
part of part of us upon which we etch
the lessons of our soul
um I'm pretty sure I'm not going to
regret not doing this
you're gonna be thinking about it for
the rest of your life
only
there's you're gone like a three-day
seminar
like if I could have a list of like all
the options I could do in my life like a
million things man
all converging timelines that would be
really far down there
let's see you can't shower you gotta
sleep on a wood board
uh you only eat [__] testicle sounds
like a great time
uh God it's still going when are you
gonna say what what is this
yeah so that was I I found this and this
seems to be the same event and this is
just like a public thing so that's why I
was saying like wait this is a different
wait what the [__] no this is the
Barbarian
no but he said this is of invite only
bro right for kings of YouTube so the
Barbarian challenge when he was here
they described it the Barbarian is that
if you scroll up
um to that uh Bird's IV shot or whatever
you want to call it
uh yeah that's the Barbarian challenge
it's like a backpack full of weights and
then more weights behind you and then
like oh you're in the middle of the
street man
you know let's not block traffic at the
very least and apparently you have to
walk with those weights for like a mile
or more here more after you're finished
pre-training optional most are ready
with no prep required some are not if
that's you I have a one-on-one guy
whatever [__] shut up
time commitment from dusk till dawn it's
a one day
safety ancestral tenant 5 is Shield
don't be a little [__] ain't nothing to
worry about we got this
thanks man I feel much more confident
every lion knows what is Right wins and
what is wrong dies
good thing we're not like have to live
like that anymore
his biological imperative is a
fundamental as nature because it is his
nature
yada yada I don't I don't understand
what that's it liver King out what is it
working out it was nothing just it
didn't say anything I don't know what's
happening
hahaha
that's the longest
so then here's the public one I guess
uh
here's a summary maybe this will give us
a better idea why modern why modern boy
men why modern day men are [__]
what does that mean it's like a lesson
that we're gonna learn it's just a
summary yeah so yeah he will uh sum that
up for you man boy into barbarian
barbarian into cave cave King cave into
[__] Kingdom
that's a summary uh-huh I feel like it's
going to be like a Napoleon Dynamite
when I went to that karate studio that
dude right but the with the American
yeah exactly oh yeah
we're good about it yeah exactly so and
then he just put toxic masculinity with
no explanation you'll be getting a lot
of that he's what where he's like no we
have it in spades
oh man why modern day are [__]
tell me suffering from low manhood low
virility virility and low testosterone
cool well I know how to fix low
testosterone with a [__] needle
that's how he did and some elixir
he did it just like his ancestors
now I don't know what you're on about
dude
this is weird what does he want from me
like genuinely to all you dads out there
that don't lift Happy Father's Day okay
okay so he made a video okay
I'm gonna check this uh audio
and be cautious
family is there why in the world bro you
are not walking around like that your
kids are gonna be so bully man
I feel bad for those little those boys
are eating raw meat and walking with
their dad who's cosplaying is like
Crocodile Dundee dude
why you look like that
today is Father's day because every day
is Father's Day in memory of my own dad
who passed when I was just two every day
is an opportunity to grow I guess that
explains the
the lack of a father figure you know
sometimes it just goes sideways
to apply the principles of your caved at
the everyday life to make the most of
the Weaponry he has armed you with for
cave dads like liver King today and
every day is Father's Day to leave from
the day it's Father's Day
provide them with a Weaponry to scale
and Lead themselves scale and lead a
team and one day to become the tip of
the [__] spear you guys are just
lifting weights it's not that serious
because they're just exercising you know
what I mean just exercise
it's good
but it's not that serious they scaled
and Lead their own tribe our dad job is
simple to affirm our boys with a depth
of challenge worth and potential to that
one day that his kids work out really
hard the only difference is they're not
on steroids all right
they're like Dad why don't I look like
you
I'll talk to you about it son when
you're 18.
I'm gonna share my secrets with you then
believe in themselves yes son you are
the Ultimate Weapon you are the creator
of your destiny yeah that's cool I have
algebra homework can I can I get to that
I think they're homeschooled bro oh yeah
um they only take classes in Butchery
right arrow shooting right that makes
sense and cave paintings
and uh
P that's right yeah what else do you
need
challenging especially when it's tiring
and always when we don't feel like the
King on the inside we owe it to them to
be the evolutionary Hunters that we were
born to be so they can grow up he's just
he's just so thirsty for purpose this
man has no purpose in his life he's
super rich
he lives on this giant Ranch by himself
nobody around except his kids he has no
purpose so he invented this whole
Barbarian thing to make it seem like you
know
he's the center of some epic adventure
but you're just it's just not that
serious man you're just dragging weights
behind you a truck can do that
John have become their own form of
on or a self-made King not self-made you
live on a [__] like 10 million dollar
Ranch dummy
self-made
that's right son
then they found some like medical supply
company or something yeah how they got
rich yeah his wife was like a dentist or
some [__] yeah my son's going to Harvard
even though he's never attended school
they're wacky Kansas dude what's going
on with dentists
I keep trying to say dentists are a
weird they're a weird bunch of folks huh
something about staring into the mouth
all day or maybe the light okay and I
mentioned that before maybe just being
around that fold it
by the way she was apparently a dentist
and now they don't believe in brushing
yeah shoot the son of a [__] so she
went to school for like 12 years to
become a doctor
and now she's like no I changed my mind
on that no brushing it's [__] and
it's such horseshit bro that's such
horseshit right I think he sprays Bo
deodorant this is this is not factuals
I'll claim I think you spray some BO
deodorant or uh uh perfume on
says he doesn't shower I think that's
[__] bad bro I smelled him that man
does not shower
Zach suggesting that this the smell was
fake somehow I don't believe that I
don't think so it was
it was ridiculously overwhelmingly
pungent well to the extent that like I
almost I almost am a little suspicious
too like how can somebody smell that bad
if you don't ever shower and you work
out all day yeah and you're super
[__] hairy
you're gonna stink he would not stop
sweating when he was in studio yeah he
had like a whole river of yeah but maybe
his titty it was the distance too like I
was over here and I smelled him the
second he entered the building like when
he stepped in the door all the way over
there
like I heard his voice and immediately
the smell hit me in the face like I
don't even know that's crazy that you
can buy because it smelled like Bo it
wasn't like a fart sure or something I
just think he's gonna be awesome if it
was like just sulfur but do you think
he's really like sleeping on a board no
that I don't buy it so you just think he
just doesn't shower or do you think he
when he goes on PR trips he just doesn't
shower for like two weeks I think he
does all this [__] for the most part but
some of it is like super embellished
like that man sleeps in like a
California king-sized bed oh man made of
horse hair and tuft and
organic cotton what I don't understand
is he's like oh I'm super Primal
ancestral tenants he worried on a
[__] hundred thousand dollar watch
like I don't think they had that when we
were cavemen so you say
one moreover I mean just the whole lying
about the story like that I don't know
how anybody can take this guy seriously
ever again I don't think anyone does
good I hope not you lost everything I
think the the whole like ancestral thing
that the entire basis of his Persona
ended up to be a a total lie he's a
complete fraud and it's like yeah why
would you listen to this guy for
anything
I think and I don't think anyone does
and I think it's comment section or just
people like amused by his people just
dunking on him well he does silly stupid
stuff still like right I will say he's
entertaining I'll give him that he's got
Charisma the whole thing although the
stick really wore out on me pretty
quickly like it was it was funny for for
a minute there but
um to all you dads out there that don't
yeah this shit's weird this is just so
crazy weird money grab this is like
desperate e-marketing [__] man
this guy cannot stop
okay
there it is nasty I was the only one
taking those liver supplements for a
little bit too and to show the
effectiveness of it uh not long after I
became a vegetarian right
you know I am that says something
uh Alex's that's not a pretty Primal
what the [__] man
that man is a demon
um we have a raging debate going on
between I made a comment on Friday that
uh I said ibuprofen
is dangerous
and would be
um not over the counter if it was
released today
and then on the subreddit I noticed
there's a there's a lot of um well
here's what I said about it let's see
let's see a little bleeding out so let's
see both Ibuprofen and Tylenol are
commonly used I know that
so here it's listing all the terrible
things about ibuprofen so Tylenol says
or sorry yeah Tylenol says the most
significant risk with Tylenol is liver
damage or failure that sounds pretty bad
especially when taken in high dose or
combined with alcohol so you kind of
gotta [__] around overdosing Tylenol I
mean that's so I was wrong about that
actually you can overdo it's easier to
overdose on Tylenol than Ibuprofen
so you can take a bunch of Tylenol and
then just die
which I guess is not as easy to do with
ibuprofen
I guess uh but I tried to do some here's
the thread
and the reason I even pull it up is the
comments are pretty funny and I don't
even know that they're right so here's
the PSA
Tylenol is way more dangerous than
Ibuprofen and it puts 1500 people in the
hospital every year you think it's
confusing what he heard about Tylenol
with Ibuprofen you can easily overdose
on Tylenol end up needing an organ
transmitter dying
that part's true actually that's an
important correction is that Tylenols
they're both I guess pretty
pretty dangerous to take yeah to overuse
or to um to combine it with alcohol or
anything am I gonna blow my nails
nice less excuse me
um
but the comments cracked me up man this
person is like on an absolute Mission
let's see
this one is is perfectly valid point
that one I like
um
uh here uh okay it looks like some of
the more psychotic ones maybe got buried
by now uh but the one I saw was on the
top about
okay this this is my favorite one this
is the op mods
it seriously worries me that Ethan has
confused what he heard about Tylenol
with Ibuprofen
popping Tylenol like candy which is not
something I don't believe I ever
advocated for
popping Tylenol like candy
I need I need receipts I don't remember
saying anything like that popping title
like candy can cause serious health
problems require liver transplant and
cause death it is Tylenol that would not
be approved by the FTA today not
ibuprofen but the best part of this is
mods
what do you what are you asking the mods
to do exactly like like what what is
what is it that you want them to do at
this moment
it seriously worries me that Ethan has
confused them
okay you have so mods reach out let's
you know let's take this seriously
didn't expect Avery to like air drop in
here or something
oh man but so the thing that I kept
thinking of oh and then this one he has
drank cold medicine straight from the
bottle on the show without measuring
seriously dangerous okay that's not true
I did it in a shot glass so we know how
much
you know
I've always been
um paranoid to dig Tylenol
it sounds like it's perfectly it's
perfectly fine just don't take too much
of it right but like I've always been
told like if if you are drinking take
ibuprofen or Advil or something like
that for like a hangover yeah that's
what I've always been told also I've
been this is irrational thought but do
you remember what happened back in the
80s with Tylenol what like one of the
one of the bottles got poison or
something it was like five people died
from that that was back when they were
there was no mods back then there was no
mods back I think that's when they added
this the seal right there was no
sealable for that but also also it was a
capsule
um rather than um what it is today and
how long ago was that I think it was
like in the 80s 85 86. all right we can
let that go by now yeah I know a
rational irrational fear yeah just
putting that out you weren't even born I
mean I wasn't even a thought you know
but imagine this at one point we almost
went to nuclear war with Russia
that's some existential dread there how
about that that's uh talk to that my
therapist there's something to keep in
mind
uh here's someone said I'm aware Tylenol
can be dangerous but my brother
literally just had to go to the hospital
for three days due to horrible kidney
values the doctor determined it was from
ibuprofen brother had been having
migraines and other body pains due to
work and stress and was just taking a
bunch of ibuprofen for a while it almost
killed him so what are you saying I am
mods I am seriously concerned that this
poster here is is uh you know
exactly they're saying pop ibuprofen
like candy
okay
mods
it's so funny man
get the mods
I'm seriously worried mods
what did that I'm genuinely curious do
anyone know what they're asking for
what do they want
just uh just to tell me
okay oh they're like worried about my
health
okay they want to save my life okay I
respect that it's a matter of time
I respect that thanks for I mean they
care and I appreciate that I will say
this conversation has uh brought to my
attention I take way too much Advil
uh interest well how much do you take uh
I probably take two every other day that
is pretty serious usage yeah you should
cut back yeah
but why you have chronic uh headaches
what do you
um
I I find that it it'll calm down uh some
anxious feelings
um really you take it for anxiety when
there's better stuff than that I I know
I'm aware of that
um I've never heard of that you take
Tylenol for anxiety yeah I don't know if
it's a placebo thing or that's what he
said Dad
Advil that's title no no no no different
oh it is yeah oh so you take ibuprofen I
take Ibuprofen yes
it helps your anxiety I don't know if
it's Placebo or what but it works
you could have you been seen a
psychiatrist I see a psychologist you
should see a psychiatrist yeah because
they you know what I mean
because I guarantee you that's probably
no it's probably not that good yeah yeah
that's a weird Zach thing I can't
imagine many people doing that just
taking Advil for anxiety every other day
yeah that's really I find it calms me
down how did you first discover that
um I think I I was having a headache one
day and I just found that it just
totally calmed me down and kind of
relaxed me and find it easier to fall
asleep
yeah for sure
no no not good well that's good we
potentially save Zach's life there you
go thank you for saving my life but that
was so we did lots of research because I
remember always hearing that like one of
these
should never have been made over the
counter and so we did all kinds of
research
um we found that both drugs are safe
when they're used as instructed and you
know Tylenol is considered one of the
safest over-the-counter medicines
apparently
uh but the reason many regard it as
dangerous
is because ibuprofen it's because
a single dose
uh can be fatal of Tylenol if you take
too much
overdose yeah whereas taken as directed
Tylenol is generally considered very
safe but you can OD on it so ibuprofen
on the other hand is
toxicity level I guess is it's it's much
rarer for people to overdose on
ibuprofen
um ibuprofen I can't read because your
cursor is covered ibuprofen
ibuprofen however also has some serious
health risks chronic long-term use can
lead to gastrointestinal bleeding kidney
problems ibuprofen can cause Market
worsening of hypertension
or developing new blood pressure uh high
blood pressure
can also damage the kidneys
worsening
of heart failure and even heart attack
hitting a stroke I don't know that
sounds good at all anxiety meds and Care
in rare cases this can be severe enough
to be light-threatening but here's the
thing if you look up any medicine side
effects it's all crazy
I haven't been able to take any pain
meds here I'm too scared that America
doesn't like regulate their dosage
because none of the stuff that's over
the counter here is
um available in Sweden in like stores I
got some Tylenol you got something yeah
right here dude ibuprofen I don't know
most of them are not available
right yeah but the red but like the
medicine is no the amount is correct
yeah I know so what do you take when you
have a headache in Sweden I don't know I
had I took some with me Swedish ones
that ever that's run probably Tylenol it
has a different name in Europe yeah I
bet it's it I'm almost sure certain it's
Tylenol they call it uh
here
it's called Uh
Paris settle Para sedimal
oh yeah that is yeah yeah that's hers
that's Tylenol okay it's the same thing
interesting so that one I'll feel safe
taking
yeah and it is safe just don't you know
just don't take a whole bottle of it and
you'll be fine yeah oh yeah I never take
it really
and yeah so I don't know what to say I
guess they're both dangerous
but uh we need to let the mods know
and as far as your uh confusion about
the if it were released today it
wouldn't be allowed to be sold over the
counter I I saw Arguments for both
Tylenol and the ibuprofen
uh Tylenol is more dangerous than
Ibuprofen it puts 1500 people in the
hospital every year oh that's that's
just the thread that's scratch that
uh but I guess Tylenol would probably be
more likely to be prescribed just
because it has a higher risk of
death overdosing yeah
so they would be like here's the amount
you take I should have claim that there
have been uh calls for ibuprofen to come
behind the counter and need a
prescription this is true for both
Ibuprofen and Tylenol people are trying
to advocate for that the awareness of
Tylenol is danger and calls for it to be
put behind the counter are more recent
but there have been studies supporting
ibuprofen being put behind the counter
as well so there you go
okay uh guys whoever's in touch with the
mods please let them know
I don't know this thread was killing me
man
so there you go
I appreciate your concern though
oh here's a doctor's comment
Tylenol is much more safe than Ibuprofen
says Dr Bob's lake house no
that's what I said originally right or I
said the opposite no no that's what I
said yeah you were saying you like
Tylenol ibuprofen yo what's happening
now op 1500 deaths a decade is peanuts
ibuprofen does 15 600 deaths
a year
however it is all medicine and all
candies will be careful about your usage
I would always recommend Tylenol as a
pain reliever over aspirin or ibuprofen
the side effects are much less than
Ibuprofen
uh yes there are some instances where
inflammatory pain like arthritis where
you choose ibuprofen but again
usually also be mindful of side effects
and prolonged use all the deaths come
from overdosing exceeding the daily
limit if you take way more than the
maximum limit you can get liver failure
but even people with severe liver
failure should be able to handle the
maximum dose maximum daily limit is 4
grams or eight so he's saying eight
Extra Strength pills per day is the
maximum dose because 500 is Extra
Strength 300 is the normal one
eight per day
taken two at a time within four hours
between it's not easy to overdose on
Tylenol you have to exceed maximum daily
limit by a lot usually there are
preventable deaths though packing and
blisters would be safer packing and
blisters oh like instead of a bottle
where you have to pop them out yeah the
bottle is kind of crazy it's just so
many
I guess now that I know this always read
the instructions and don't use ibuprofen
because you think it's safer it isn't
also listen to chat gbt for medical
don't listen well hold on I was right
you weren't right about that part
no because you listen to chat GPT for
medical information all the time hold on
hold on
but I was right and the doctor co-signs
me he's co-signing chat gbt somebody on
Reddit who says that they're a doctor
they very well maybe like else is lying
I'm I'm just saying maybe
a Reddit thread on our h3h3 Productions
is not the place to uh to settle this is
he finished he said it very confidently
they said it very confidently I should
say I believe I choose to believe him
okay but seriously Tylenol well then in
that case we're the mods we need to take
care of the original poster of this
thread wait this is mods we need to get
a hold of Sophie he's got it totally
backwards yo he's got it totally
backwards we got to get a hold of him
oh
so fun so crazy
we got the best we got the best
community man
truly
um
thank you
what is this I just got out breaking
Howie Mandel news yeah speaking of mods
what the [__] thumbnails out of control
Howie look at the title
Howie Mandel does tana [__] live
what the [__] well look at the thumbnail
sorry
mods mods
dude
okay so Howie decided he doesn't need to
be in the thumbnail now all of a sudden
all right
interesting very very interesting
wow how he's coming up big time huh
he pulled he pulled Tana
just learning the game the mods on this
mods mods can you do something about
that mods it's my turn to play the
PlayStation
so funny
uh okay so there you go thank you
everybody we hope we've all learned
something really valuable today learned
a lot
let's do a poll and then this will
decide which is more dangerous Tylenol
or Ibuprofen and now this will be the
decider that will all accept from now on
was that a good idea yes yeah it's a
phenomenal idea
you think the chat if we just
crowdsource it from the chat it'll
definitely be accurate
that's my point
the people are never wrong
so this this this will um
settle the debate once and for all and
mods the question is which one is more
dangerous yeah which one is more
dangerous ibuprofen or Tylenol yeah
and mods I hope you're watching because
this is relevant
yeah highly relevant eyes up Mods eyes
open eyes up
all right so I'm voting for ibuprofen
because apparently
Tylenol is God's drug
according to but Dr Bob's lake house the
doctor
so it's 50 50 like even after all that I
mean it's so silly maybe both dangerous
they are both dangerous Point yeah yeah
like most drugs I ain't taking my [__]
[__] I mean you know you could take too
much I've heard of people taking too
much melatonin and dying true
that's so interesting that you say that
yeah
it's called drowning
um
no it's not you can drink too much water
that's true too of I was making a
drowning joke but yeah yeah but yes you
can also just water is deadly
very deadly in fact
my mom always said you can drown in a
teaspoon of water so you have to be
careful
but there you go the people have spoken
so guys beware of ibuprofen ibuprofen's
the devil Tylenol is the god
Tylenol like candy ibuprofen never under
any excuse
5644 pole that's what we've learned of
course I'm kidding follow the
instructions listen to your doctor
listen to doctors instructions of course
it seems like they're both dangerous you
know
they both could be uh by prescription
only yeah
that's what it is
how hard is it to understand used as
directed right yeah
it's not like one of the good drugs like
weed or alcohol that you can just take
an unlimited amount of yeah there's
there's no recommended amount of alcohol
yeah no it's just whatever have added
whatever you can fit a great pain
reliever too
right it's the biggest trick in the year
exactly you get it
all right let's uh solves the anxiety
Zach no you could try that I hear it
just takes a zipper sipper too three
sips three steps I also find that I can
get like um like carpal tunnel like I
find that like my fingers are uh so
Advanced Weed and Alcohol yeah yeah are
you getting sticky like how's it feel in
your fingers like uh oh I play guitar
yeah I push keys for a living so like I
you know you're a Lego man too yeah so
so I I there's exercises you can do to
prevent carpal tunnel I know I do I do
uh these finger stretches
um that I read online that are pretty
that's good yeah but this is one I
learned in typing class in fifth grade
and I remembered it I don't know why I
feel like it can't be real she says
turning the doorknob turning the
doorknob yeah like I get in my we like
turning the doorknob I'm wrist
a lot
yeah yeah we turned when I broke my arm
I I broke it right here and I did this
with a towel twisting it's kind of the
same thing to like work up the muscle so
yeah oh I'll give it another shot so
we're turning the door knob yeah all
right we're opening the door and
stepping into a healthier area wrist
Cameron take notes let me try it hold on
open this door I just have a
chiropractor
okay Cam snap them open the door and or
twist the knob okay now open the door
what do you see behind the door
I don't wanna
go through it all right Drifters
shooting up let's see we've got the
cringe couple of the year
the YouTube prankster got shot that
one's pretty good that's very good this
one's quite good this guy lamino who
makes these super long detailed um
reaction videos that was this is one of
the guys who was famously ripped off
by a bunch of twitch streamers uh-oh and
so xqc goes I always get permission I
always get permission you keep trying to
tell me that not that anything matters
anymore but
he came out and made a video I think
it's pretty interesting actually
he's this is the guy that made the JFK
assassination video right uh I'm not
sure let me double check it was like a
hour long super highly edited and
researched video and they were they were
all just watching it with zero
commentary
yeah that's him
yeah so he was at the heart of all this
it was kind of interesting that he
actually he's putting out a statement
it's only two minutes let's hear him out
and essentially re-uploading it but
let's start with this one for those
unaware there's been this ongoing debate
for several years now regarding what's
known as reaction content the appeal of
which is to watch someone a similar
voice
it's just the voiceover
zesty yeah zesty zesty
to other people's videos after some of
these channels reacted to my latest
video and videos
made by a few other creators the debate
started all over again which is what
this question is referring to I don't
mind people reacting to my videos but I
do mind when they play the entirety of
my video a face cam in the corner with
the occasional Interruption does nothing
to address that issue my video is still
being played from beginning to end in
someone else's stream or video it's
neither ethical nor necessary listen bro
it's cool that you have that opinion but
where's your proof that it didn't get
you more views
checkmate
if in the how can you prove that the
drop-off wouldn't have been more Sharp
yeah yeah true checkmate could have been
worse
you can never disprove that theory xqc
is such a [__] idiot
guys just to provide commentary on that
work if movie review channels can
function without playing the entire
movie then so too can reaction channels
no indeed some of them do precisely they
can't because
their whole system of content production
is contingent upon
zero effort super long
content they got to stream like eight
hours a day
because of their twitch contracts
and so they need a ton of [__] to watch
without any uh thought for thought
so
careful where you're treading there
buddy stepping on a lot of toes
but you know they'll play a brief clip
of what they're watching followed by
their reaction even streamers can do
things like only show the progress bar
thereby forcing viewers to seek at the
original you're [__] dreaming if you
think anyone would do that
can you imagine that's crazy
I love his ideas but and I fully support
him by like he's right 100 by the way
I'm being being sarcastic uh yeah up and
watch along with the streamer well you
know they could do the bare minimum and
ask for permission something that none
of the major reaction channels have ever
done but they've streamed no major
reaction channels have asked this man
for permission and this is one of the
most highly
reacted to videos on Twitch they all
have a re-upload of this [__] so who
would it why do they keep lying and
saying they ask permission you just you
don't
stop lying dude
seem to re-upload my videos I highly
recommend this video by the channel
legal eagle that was a bit of this whole
thing in more detail with a focus on the
illegality of it all and there are
plenty of other videos on this topic as
well I don't really know what should be
done about this because there's clearly
an audience for this type of content
banging it outright might work
you know it might just push that
audience to a platform that does allow
for reaction content I think the ideal
solution would be for YouTube and other
platforms to implement some sort of free
action feature perhaps when you click on
a reaction video you're taken to the
watch page of the video being reacted
too but with elements of the person
reacting being layered on top it's
interesting that is interesting that's a
really good idea it's a good idea I have
to imagine from an engineering
standpoint probably pretty tricky to do
but I mean
yeah that would like solve all the
problems that's wild
zesty or well I guess technically you
could still sue them but
so what would it be it'd be like if
you're live
and then you use this function
it counts it as if all of your live
viewers are also watching like it would
like right now we have about 45 000
people watching so if we did a react to
a long video it would give that person
45 000 views I don't know how that would
work I was I thought effectively
everybody that I was watching our stream
is now watching the video you're right
you're right
it's very comp it's just like I mean I
don't know it's you guys know how I feel
about it
it's just silly because there's all
these twitch streamers that people like
and it's just like become totally fine
to steal people's content now because
they're cool dudes doing it now and not
dumbasses that are easy to dunk on
Ludwig by the way who everybody loves
and I'm not I'm just singling them out
because I saw it on the so somebody sent
it to me he [__] was playing a
podcast clip and walked away from the
room for 25 minutes while the podcast
played
for his audience our podcast yeah ours
or I'll pull I'll pull the uh clip
and I mean you know it may have been an
accident oh you got it thank you baby
so is this a sleep stream I'm someone
like donated
for that to play it's 11 hours 12 hours
a sleep stream can we not do that
anymore [__] is this
what the video or what no it's sleep
stream yeah
it's sorry yep so so while you while I
sleep enjoy this podcast
so he plays the stuff what
am I [__] for real sorry yeah here
let me see when it transitions a lot of
people even watch this is this so yeah
there's like a there's like browser
add-ons where chat could play games or
they could suggest videos that's what
love is talking about to be played I
think the videos thing is kind of insane
but yeah it's just like they're
basically like hanging out in a Discord
server but in or on Twitch rather
but feeding a streamer views and money
well he sleeps a lot of the times this
is just take the night off next level
dude what the [__] I think it's pretty
common to be honest with you again okay
I've done it yeah I don't want to say
that but I I I just have to do it and
you have your audience pull up videos no
no no no I don't have anything I
literally just have the lights off I
have the sound off it's oh I only have
to acknowledge it because I know people
are good so people watch you sleep
I no I I usually walk off camera that's
it no you just keep it open just keep it
open that's it
but I've seen people so people can come
in and chat yeah look theoretically
that's fine with me they're not there's
nothing they're not doing anything wrong
but this playing video [__] is nuts let
me see this aesthetic I hate it I get
angry I'm sure I'm sure you like you
you're just like Ah that's a weird
comment you move on with your day I read
that man I'm just like what is the
matter with you you become let me just
fast forward so that's his own video so
yeah and then whatever I don't know if
it could be something like that it may
have autoplayed maybe let's see
um
where's my American Friends
by the way they all do this too God
such a good way to get people to pay you
watch an extra hour of every episode
only if you pay us on patreon I was
thinking about doing that for the
members only on Friday
we end and then continue for members
I could never do that oh it's like just
one time I know I know and like hey I
know it drives crazy
but I I can never do that my show is
free for the people
you know what I mean sure sure I'm for
the people and let it be known that
forever and always
but boy we could get paid
I don't want to volunteer anyone or
suggest this and people not like it but
if we really want a juice we should do
like a 48 hour in the studio sleep
stream see who's see who stays the
longest or who's willing to wow I mean
that could be fun that sounds insane all
weekend
but wait
so what's the objective just as you
stays up longer
it would have to be like a personal like
I'll leave right now it sounds like fun
but
it sounds like a Mr Beast video
yeah I'd stay in the office forever if I
was gonna say It's Gonna be Me In Love
like we were in the casino mean love
were the last two there when we went to
Vegas
um so hold on let's see this transition
this is in New Hampshire we do this that
like at the
so yeah it auto plays okay so it just
autoplayed well I mean
okay inevitably that was gonna happen
exactly all right exactly
like again is this like 20 people
watching this
maybe we have like thousands of people
thousands it's thousands yeah
no this is just a random oh this is a
VOD oh okay yeah I'm sure that
it had a lot of viewers but like I guess
on this on this instance it's a it's a a
mistake it auto played
but still people if people weren't so
comfortable with the idea of stealing
people's content and just playing it
without any reaction then he would have
disabled autoplay a long time ago
and made sure that this would never
happen right minus the uh the playing of
other people's content I could see how
sleep streams could be relaxing for
people there you go like it it makes you
feel like you know like hey oh if you
want to start winding down you know
you're not alone there you go we're
winding down together yeah wonderful
[Music]
thank you Zach having said that don't
put some [__] on
the screen just put the camera on easy
the thing is we put we put so much
effort into the show like I don't want
to put the show behind a paywall I want
everyone to be able to watch it
I think that's the really cool thing
about what we do is that you don't need
to pay anyone you just need Internet
it's [__] awesome
[__] awesome dude yeah no I do like
that we do that I mean most podcasts
that I have listened to over the years
have either
a premium subscription thing required or
do a hybrid thing
um like you were describing where either
the last hour of the show is behind a
paywall or every other episode is free
you know what I mean one free one paid
episode
but I think it is cool that we do it
because I think of it you know
especially now that we do them all live
and we're live almost every day of the
week it reminds me when I'm dating
myself here but it reminds me of um you
know like talk radio that's what I
that's it yeah I mean like obviously
you've referenced Howard as like kind of
an inspiration for this show many times
but yeah I mean I used to listen talk
radio when I worked as a driver all the
time you just put it on all day and it's
there for you yeah that's what I wanted
to do and it's awesome that we can do it
I guess radio's the last time you could
like just turn something on for free and
listen I put Howard on uh every morning
when I wake up first there you go
for the people you guys
a month well no he used to be on the
race when we were growing up yeah it
used to be you just turn on the radio
and you got I mean you do have you do
have the Tuesday member stream so it's
not like you don't do that at all well
yeah but I don't even think that gained
us any members I don't think you could
put on it might lose this members yeah
exactly yeah you arguing with them so
someone said see you next week there's
just Ethan chewing for an hour yeah
chewing for an hour and arguing there's
not there's there's dogs
in yourself the thing is it's not the
main product it's like some silly weird
Vortex right if if it were an episode
with all of us here in the studio it's
not premium content yeah put it that way
shout out to all the viewers less than
premium yeah sub premiums you gotta let
me fix your ship before the show
tomorrow
what was wrong with it didn't we fix it
we got it working well enough but
let's do it we'll we'll work on it
tomorrow before okay 10 minutes before I
go live
that's what happened last week no we'll
figure it out well last week there was
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
I'm Gonna Catch You or nice and early
all right sounds
uh sounds good but you know it's like
just played 25 minutes my podcast
I mean
it's not a big deal right I don't
actually care at all but
the culture of it is is
yeah it's a little presumptive I liked
the guy's suggestion obviously that
would
require
some engineering on the platforms part
but I think I think he's right I mean
there there is
when you talk about like the product
there's like
there's the video and people have a
desire to watch that video and then
there is a subset of people that just
have a desire to watch their favorite
personalities watching stuff that is a
different thing but like there's got to
be some Middle Ground here where
everybody can win just because people
want it doesn't mean that it's a good
idea like you could say that about like
oh yeah I just want to watch brand new
movies out and I like to watch it with
my buddy who streams it's like the only
difference is that movies are more
funded and have uh lawyers that's the
only difference right right that they
can actually enforce their uh somehow
they all understand I can't watch a
brand new movie with with my stream but
when it comes to stealing podcasts and
videos on YouTube they don't give a
single [__] it is the there's no
measurable difference between I mean
functionally it's pretty much the same
you're right it is identical twitch has
the function right now where you can do
watch parties with prime where if you
could like and when you do do that it
like your viewers if they have Prime are
watching just the movie and then the
your box your stream is separated
completely
and they could do something like that I
feel like where
if you're gonna watch someone else's
content they'll get the views right it
pulls it up on everybody else's browser
as well so they you can like remote
control kind of like what I was saying
before it's like if we were to watch a
video right now we have 56 or 46k people
watching it would open the video for all
of them individually and that person
would get 46 000 views roll it there's a
chrome plug in there you're actually
bringing the views to somebody and that
seems mutually beneficial right although
you could still technically be sued but
I think it'd be a lot less likely if
they were benefiting right there's
ultimately you're still making you're
still using their unlicensed content I
suppose
you know
but um roll it like right that is that
is interesting because I wonder would it
be supplanting the original if they're
all watching there I mean
like it's kind of a way it's an
interesting
because your only content is just
through the reaction so it should be
fine right yeah because like on like
well no just be on your stream though
you'd be showing it here no your stream
would be full cam oh well then there's
no problem yes yeah and with the watch
parties it separates it so the VOD won't
have any of that in there and the video
itself like if a watch party started and
the Creator like rewinds or pauses it it
doesn't do that for the audience like it
it it it's not synced up in that way
they're not seeing your screen you have
to and you have to mute the audio coming
out so does anyone use that feature it's
not it's not that popular no yeah it's
very why would they clunky and like and
you you have to go it's for Prime video
right which like I get is also Amazon
but you're leaving twitch to do this I
feel like if it was all on one platform
it was YouTube had the ability to open
up I mean YouTube already on browser has
the ability to do picture-in-picture
with like you know it makes like the
little mini window or whatever like if
you could
have your channel go small and then it
opens it up opens up another video for
everybody so there is already I don't do
that streamers will use it and here's
why because they'll make a lot less
money and get a lot less
attention and they can't do YouTube
highlights I mean it proves just how
PR how you know
exploitative the current system is
nobody's using that and they wouldn't so
I'm hearing um just to exonerate lubric
a little bit in this situation that it
it does appear to be a mistake uh this
is from one of our mods mods I got the
context for the Ludwig thing in the
specific stream apparently for that
specific stream it wasn't audience
submitted his team meant to only play
all episodes of his pod and for some
reason it messed up and autoplayed your
POD at one point but they got it fixed
and set back to Auto playing all the
episodes of his bots so the YouTube
algorithm somehow
I mean I love that that it recommended
I'll take the recommendation sure yeah I
love that [__] boy so yeah it sounds
like it was not uh malicious well that
being said I do still I'm gonna need a
licensing fee watching my algorithms get
crushed chat is mentioning will nap's
watch parties which I recently found
where he does it properly where it's oh
he does yeah he he likes for him he
doesn't show anything when he's watching
a movie he doesn't play anything it's
just his reaction and you and he has the
responsibility
like what we do with the boxing events
right right okay oh I know Joe Rogan
does that when he watches the UFC stuff
so yeah I mean that's a way to do it but
obviously it's going to exclude a lot of
people in
Ludwig are we saying his name wrong
people are saying a Ludwig
or is that a meme it's Ludwig
okay that's what I thought
or did someone say Ludwig probably
Ludwig
anyway he's almost done with this video
I don't know he
hey it's a complicated topic that's
certainly not going to be solved by me
right here and now but to ask you a
question no I don't want people to
stream or re-uploaded the entirety of my
videos there you go see the man finally
we couldn't have possibly predicted a
stand for people stealing his content
and re-uploading it
no one could have ever known
there it is so shout outs I never saw
his um JFK video who did it was the
conclusion bro you want to know who did
it everyone yo I'll show you it's like a
whole ass Feeding Frenzy just like me
oh wait no this is everyone hold on
good Channel his videos are crazy y'all
should check him out let me know if
you're not familiar so here's the
Kennedy assassination and it's an hour
and a half
7.5 million and this is like crazily
produced really good and so here's what
everyone did they take the exact
title and now let's see
let's see who comes up
this was my ass
our boy excuse me he's right there baby
let's go
um
you just passed one
the other one that he had in the thing I
see that that one's only 40 minutes
though so I'm assuming that one actually
is probably fairies
it's vlogging through history I think
this guy's a fair use guy
okay but here let's type the Kennedy
assassination
you didn't answer my question who killed
Kennedy
mods
it seems like it was not a mystery it
seems like it's pretty much exactly
as it was recounted
it sounds like a [__] video then
sounds boring
xqc Hassan now
okay this this is one of the length of
the video this is one of the channels
who
who does it without his permission uh he
doesn't benefit from pull out that being
said
he should make a better effort to remove
this
because ultimately it is his content
even though he's not benefiting from it
these channels are [__] man there's
probably just too many
well that's true but we dmca we DM state
it like one time and then they never did
it again because they're so scared
that's right wait go to oldest remember
when we did that on that one channel it
was like the weird like kids cartoons
look at this channel though they're
making him look bad too because they're
they're just doing like xqc Style
full stream rips like
you know you can click on oldest I was
curious if it has
oh no I think okay name yeah or maybe
they purged it I don't know
they could have purged it yeah probably
did once we pointed it out
so
okay
one of the Hassan
[__] your schemers how about that
um
destiny
uh
uh I don't know why it's showing more
Hassan
here's me
there's us let's react to that
critical watched it again it seems like
a lot of people are just
ripping the streamer's content sqc seems
like the only one psycho
uh a biggest piece of [__] enough to
actually just upload it full sale on his
own channel
you know I've always said that I'm not
I'm against I would never sue another
creator
but this one's getting pretty close to
being justifiable here all right I think
it's totally just follow I think someone
should sue X you see I mean
I think they should do it man
I'm I'm down with that I support that
all right
okay
okay I'm thinking about suing them too
uh let's see
more L's from alpha douche no we don't
do that one
let's do the prankster who got shot this
is awesome
so uh this took place in a mall I wish I
could show you the whole video but shoot
the son of a [__] it's not it's not
even like graphic
you don't see anything you just well you
you do see the the gun you see the gun
for YouTube to be like
Omi took it like a champ though well you
eat I don't he just fell off frame I
didn't even see what happened I mean he
grunted and fell collapsed to the ground
it took it like a champ I don't know
hahaha
[Laughter]
JFK took it like a champ yeah he sure
did man
uh
this is his channel the dude's a dumbass
yeah I mean oh and he uploaded a video I
got shot wait this happened two months
ago
yeah they just made the verdict every
time we're hearing exactly how it sounds
led to a shooting inside Dulles Town
epic bro I got shot
subscribe for more pranks
uh so here's the edit we made yeah this
guy Alan Cole he's no no the guy who
shot him is 31. he looks way older yeah
he's 31.
it's like 50. so he shot 21 year old
YouTuber who runs
classified goons Channel this is from
April by the way Goons
um
goon's channel has a bunch of cringe
pranks such as pretending to vomit on
Uber drivers following unsuspected
customers and department stores so as
you can imagine the worst of the worst
in terms of just being a menace a giant
piece of [__]
we've seen them all a thousand times
yeah so here he is in a mall I don't
even know what he's trying to do but you
can he's being really obnoxious
[Music]
like I mean that's a pretty clear sign
not interested to just quit it's uh he's
using Google translator to say hey
[__] quit thinking about my twinkle
what yeah that's not even like remotely
funny he just keeps replaying it
and so the guy's like yo what's
happening uh you know clearly this dude
is probably not all there
since he's walking around a mall with a
loaded gun
and shoots this guy at the drop of a
dime
so so where we cut it basically this is
what happens
he's got he just goes like that it's so
fast yeah it happens
you just shoots him once and then
continues walking and the prankster just
whimpers and that's basically it
um at the food court no less man don't
let me die in the food court yeah the
guy was a delivery driver he was picking
up food man
man was just trying to do he's on the
clock he's probably getting [__] with
all day those guys
so let's see uh recur the food court
can be seen following Coley around the
mall uh while thrusting his phone in his
face
as it said the phrase that AB did uh
explain Coley who has a license to carry
a concealed weapon was found not guilty
of aggravated malicious wounding in the
shooting after he said he was acting in
self-defense
this is very interesting
I'm on one hand
I totally understand and think it's dope
that that dude got shot
and I feel like the majority of people
are like the I'm so glad that one of
these pranksters got shot that is but on
the other hand if you watch the video
seems like an overreach that
[__] shot way too fast yeah that
was nice his life was not in danger it
was almost 20 seconds in total that we
were a bit dramatic so like I understand
like the impulse to cheer that a
prankster got shot
because I'm right there with you but on
the other hand
we I don't think that being a obnoxious
prankster is a death sent should be a
death sentence right you know yeah
there's a degree of
proportionality here I'm afraid I'm I'm
amazed that they acquitted him of of the
shooting I mean what the [__] I mean if
you watch it there was
it was just what state was this in this
was in uh Virginia yeah
our food court a little different down
here in Virginia
what no it wasn't in Virginia oh it
wasn't
yeah where'd you get that yeah it's in
Virginia south of Sterling Virginia oh a
food court in Sterling Virginia
uh
he was found guilty on a lesser charge
of shooting into an occupied dwelling
but a judge will hear arguments to set
aside this conviction at a hearing next
month
after as a lawyer appealed the jury was
divided on whether Coley had acted in
self-defense but after that's okay I
apologize the reason I was so confused
by that there were two incidents like
this
another YouTuber got shot in in Texas
was it that it was it the kid that was
doing like a penny I remember some kid
got Merck killed by a gang member
pranksters no that's the Virginia one
I'm so confused okay that was wrong it
was in Virginia
we're down here in Virginia
you don't want to mess with no one in
the food court
I'll tell you wait me you ain't never
know who's strapped
and we take our noodles very seriously
don't be coming at me when I'm eating
that
Mr corn dog you understand
that's right
[Music]
um
the jury was divided on whether Coley
acted in self-defense but after
additional deliberation they reached a
verdict let's go
by the man himself couldn't be my great
client here shot somebody
I feel like his YouTube channel was the
best defense
um because his YouTube channel like
there's just going through his videos
there are so many videos where he's like
harassing people to the point where it's
like I'm surprised he wasn't shot
earlier they're like look at how
annoying this guy is yeah well I like I
understand his position too in that
he clearly was like get away from me he
was physical with him get out of my face
yeah and then he continues to follow him
with his phone in his face but you know
in Virginia uh a wrong look get you a
self-defense I'll tell you what brother
we shoot first and figure out the
self-defense second
I don't know anything about Virginia
it was true I'll give that disclaimer
I don't know what the people there are
like I don't know what they eat I don't
know how many of them have guns
and I don't know what they sound like
probably they sound like me
but I do know Virginia is a good old
state
[Music]
pretty
good
that's what I'm talking about
I'm about to give this fool a country
road to walk on home to Heaven thank you
West Virginia oh Aunt Oliver Anthony is
Virginian so that tells me all I need to
know
if you don't like fudge rounds here in
Virginia
[Music]
that's such an insane line
those lyrics are not only insane but
very bad
yeah now it's bad
you know it's just the bar is so low for
conservative losers like you don't
the song is not that good
I mean it's he's good he's okay but I'm
pretty sure you know the lyrics could be
some work
[Music]
yo they'll tell me this is real cam
what the [__] yeah this is actually
Dallas
yo what does that mean uh it's just a
pink prank bro
Subway on Elm Street November 2nd on
November 22nd 1963. Subway yeah
I've been at Subway in a minute man
should I get Subway
is it even food I don't know anymore
the bread is like non-existent it's like
literally sawdust
Jersey Mike's is the uh Superior
sandwich I kind of like how they [__]
with Subway though like you can get so
much veggies on it
yeah Jersey Mike's they operate inside
in uh in Shadow
yes you don't see it's in a box you
don't see how they make them that's so
true Subway it's right there for you you
like subway yeah wait what are you
talking about what are you talking about
hold on what do you mean they operate
inside a box what does that mean they
operate in Shadow they're a shadow
organization
you don't get to tell them you don't be
like a little more lettuce yeah you can
no let me see how the sausage gets made
at Jersey Mike's let me see that's the
biggest [__] let me look let me look
Jersey Mike's ordering counter let me
see what this looks like
what
they chill out take it easy
this is Jersey Mike's oh it's the same
thing it's just like subway exactly oh
okay oh I thought Jersey Mike's had like
a restaurant restaurant I don't know
tables in a back that's just a picture
bro I don't know new conspiracy like
what's in here it's not
they actually you know what I take it
back I don't think that you can I think
there's Shadow org yeah
you conspiracy theory unlocked that done
right there is just a picture I haven't
seen that place in my life
we don't believe nothing we can't see
with our own two eyes
check out Jersey Mike's in Hoboken New
Jersey
Lina used to work at a subway for years
and uh they offered halal meat but they
weren't supposed to so whenever the like
subway reps came in she had to hide the
meat what yeah wait wait wait wait wait
they what they're like do not serve
halal meat yeah because it wasn't
actually like their product this was
just like the owner because
he's a franchisee he wants to sell
sandwiches yeah
oh that's interesting for the people
good man God bless him man [__] Subway
God bless the food oh that's awesome so
he snuck his Halal meats in yep was
there like a secret word I don't know I
wish it was here but there was a lot of
interesting stuff going on there they
had like a bunch of stuff in the
basement too that they were like selling
like clothes and stuff randomly
yeah it was an interesting place
sweet it's a One-Stop shop that is
interesting I need new new shoes I'm
gonna stop by Subway on the way home
absolutely
um okay what were we talking about oh
yeah what were we talking about this
dude Mike's is a conspiracy
um
I think
that
they have less emphasis on customization
you're saying you don't like Jersey mics
I don't like it as much as Subway I find
it's too meaty I agree
they put like way too much meat I
[__] love Subway and I like the other
stuff there needs to be a beautiful
balance it's like
at Subway is not me
so
who said that not meat who said me
the meat is not meat it's not me
do you want to expand on that I just
heard it's not it's just not turkey the
tuna's not Tuna the Tuna one that was a
scandal but the meat is meat and that
was a scandal it was the crab one wasn't
the seafood one they used to be my
favorite I think it was the tuna look I
enjoy Subway I'm just saying Jersey
Mike's is superior since when do we care
what kind of I just eat it is yummy
pockets it's fast food yeah we're not
eating it first I don't care what I mean
I mean [__] come on huh you know what
I'm saying plastic screenshot things
so anyway he got off
uh pressure argue that the facts did not
support a self-defense claim as Coastal
action was seen as bizarre but not
life-threatening
Cole did not reasonably fear imminent
bodily harm
to prove aggravated malicious wounding
and malicious discharge of a firearm the
jury needed to find that Coley acted
with malice which would not apply if he
was responding to a pro a provocation of
reasonably aroused fear anger okay so by
that metric he's he's definitely not
guilty I don't think you could prove
that he shot him with malice he was
definitely provoked
free my boy
free coley
oh wait what so was Subway acquitted
look at what maybe he just sent yo what
lawsuit followed by a woman claiming
Subway's tuna isn't no I thought it was
like an analysis
oh this woman okay she filed a lawsuit
based on this analysis I think tuna Saga
started in 2021 after lawsuit prompted
Shane to defend itself okay hold on
let's keep going down
that's it oh
you want a closer look at this sandwich
that looks disgusting
here let me let me just like one two
curdles of corn
okay slay
I am oh she looks good today
cute I love her makeup is that a smoky
eye
yes it looks like it is
maybe some metallic Shimmer on there
what is happening here is it possible
that the blood of circulation got shut
off the half her brain I
played yes and I
am okay
okay
[Music]
at separate news here's another
prankster been concerned terrorizing
people she and her sister were left
traumatized by one of his pranks at the
Target in Sterling early last month she
describes them more as harassment we
were approached by a man who was wearing
a security shirt he came up to my sister
and I and stated that there was a known
stalker in the Target who he noticed had
been following us he said he's Gothic he
is wearing dark eyeliner dark lipstick
we look over and we see the gothic
gentleman standing there staring she
says that security man helped walked
into the checkout line that's such a
[__] awesome prank yo there's like a
murderer he's like a convicted murderer
rapist I've seen him in the news that's
him he's following you yesterday so this
is the same kid and he was doing this
prank just oh same kid yeah yeah he was
doing this a few weeks before he got
shot so this kid was gonna get shot it
was just a matter of time yeah
and he said
in the original report I saw
he said what's next for the YouTube
prankster I'm gonna get out there and
keep doing my thing oh yeah brother yeah
what's interesting about him is uh not
to talk about his sub count but he has
57k subs like usually when these guys
are putting themselves In Harm's Way I
feel like they're Bradbury numbers you
know like in the millions but he doesn't
care no but you gotta you gotta grind at
that low level man you got to prove that
you're different
you're right it didn't pan out and
that's devastating it might actually be
his big bag
this could be his big break let's give
him a plug what's his name this could be
his big bang his name is uh classified
goons all right the Goon Squad
so-called stalker kept following them
the next day she reported what happened
to Target in the Loudoun County
Sheriff's Office she claims it was
Tanner cook posing a nice [__] high
def photo y'all got of him man yeah
stunning I uh High death
yo I know him if you see this man run
[Laughter]
I [__] know this guy
oh [__]
as the security
and wearing the same fake security shirt
scene in his recording that's for sure
illegal right to go in a store and like
impersonate security probably not
gotta be I doubt it
I don't know it seems a little sus
inside other targets her experience was
never posted on the channel the
intention in my opinion is he's he's in
trying to instill fear and it worked
Allen Cole is accused of critically
shooting cook while he was
let this man out dude he did nothing
wrong
quick Google search says it is illegal
yeah generally illegal to impersonate a
security guard yeah I'm seeing that too
that seems like super
fussy because it's a licensed position
and the penalty is getting shot death
yep but well to be fair in America today
the penalty for any crime is pretty much
death absolutely as long as the the
right police show up yeah
it's Town Center the Loudoun County
Commonwealth attorney's office says
you like it is he one of those smizing
for real like Tyra would really oh [__]
Blue Steel
he's smiling with his eyes
what do they call it there's like a
whole subreddit for like jailhouse
cuties or hotties or something oh
she just looks like John Connor in the
reality where he never
Judgment Day never happens there's a
real mugshots Twitter account that posts
a lot of like quote unquote hot mugshots
hold on this looks kind of good actually
that looks delicious
oh wow I'm hungry now
let's see what was different with that
that bread looks good hold on this looks
kind of good
eat fresh dude real tuna too real tuna
real bread not saw that this looks nice
and crispy that's good prankadillas Town
Center uh uh free calling man
let him out this is him and his mom
finding out uh talking about the verdict
right after you know what I say not only
let him out
let's put him in charge of Mall security
let's give him more guns yeah and more
Authority he'll stop those uh masks
I'll tell you what ain't no one's
stealing Snickers from this under this
watch
so this is the kid's mom him and his mom
yeah Mom you failed
you're failed oh my God
you know we respect what the jury says
um and my family and I are just grateful
and thankful that I have my son here oh
that's right nothing else matters right
that's a Grace that's a gracious
response actually she had something
wrong with your screen oh mods oh I know
it is I know it's wrong I didn't pull it
up I'm just watching it on my [__]
laptop done
I am highly concerned mods
okay so here's his mom who actually was
very um
classy but they had to say
at the end of the day
you know we respect what the jury says
um and my family and I are just grateful
and thankful that I have my son here and
nothing else matters right now and
that's that's it I want to thank the
prosecutors the Commonwealth prosecutors
uh Miss Jones and uh
um Eden Holmes they did an outstanding
job presenting this case and we couldn't
have had it any better and regardless of
the outcome you know the jurisdiction
bro you are such an attention [__]
[__] he's gonna come here and try to
make a scene yeah oh just wait
where was he shot and his liver and
stomach yeah what why did he walk that
off like nothing in the liver Zach was
right
I was right about what took it like a
[__] he did no God just said I don't
want him
I haven't ain't ready for these Franks
yeah
we totally respect how our law plays out
and this was the outcome today and we
respect that yeah bro you are so not
funny just real quick uh Tanner you said
you wanted to I love this the people who
he's walking away like he's about
getting big Scandal that's one reporter
um
I don't know
I guess we'll just have to keep watching
yo you'll continue to make videos yeah
probably we'll see you know how
disappointed are you about this so I
really don't care I mean it is what it
is it's God's plan at the end of the day
so
man I don't see there's proof that God
doesn't exist again
the plan is for me to get murdered I get
shot in the liver because God's plan the
way the Earth is probably better off
without me so
you're reading it wrong he sees he
doesn't see it that way and God saved
God save that he can prank more I see
laughs
he did say
that was really dramatic yeah
it looks like he's like lost faith in
God
[Music]
even the reporters thinking about it my
man knows how to turn it off some
Anchorman [__] he did say despite all of
this he will plan to he still plans to
create more videos for his YouTube
channel there is another hearing though
for the guilty verdict his defense for
Coley is wanting this to be set aside
since the self-defense claims uh really
apply my man
I think him I think him and Coley should
collab on something that'd be a good way
to squash the beef YouTube Style
you know shoot the son of a [__]
they you know be funny if they collabed
and and did a sec he pranked him again
and they fake that he shoots him again
but they fake it it's every good they're
definitely gonna do that I feel like we
got to get Coley in on that man oh no it
happened again
wait it's the same guy not again
I would love if him and Jimmy just ran
into each other randomly
and just sees what comes out of that
Jimmy shoots him
so this is his channel
Jimmy's arms man
um here's his shadow I'm kind of curious
let's see I got shot I love he's so
stoked about it
I got shot like it's just like another
prank
I got shot prank
I was shot in the liver and stomach
probably could have got a lot more views
with a better thumbnail that was like
yeah if I clicked on a video that was
titled I got shot prank I would not
expecting to have taken place no it's
not I'm about to take this camera I
would have been like oh they're
pretending to get shot listen
he has a he's a long way to go fake
vomiting on Uber driver that'll be funny
angry guy charges cameraman that's funny
detained at the airport
asking strangers to watch their tone
thick epic if you scroll down a little
bit more
yeah around here get to the left of that
yeah these two those are great titles
deliberately filming people's face
pranks accusing people of stealing pets
from PetSmart prank
awesome
oh that seems like he's been uh getting
more
more wild with it
like this
this puking on Uber driver wants pretty
well guys
he wants to throw up on me okay
what year is it bro Olivia's losing it
man
that's crazy that you just did the just
do this [__] yeah
I don't want to bully on a child because
he does look young how old is he that's
been a minute
um
is 21. okay every single one says and
let me say that
[Music]
this is a serious message to all victims
of goblin mode I would like to issue an
apology
it wasn't that funny no and it just
could only could only serve to get us in
trouble not not enough I wasn't enough
you guys want that merge so also I'm
only dropping a limited amount and once
they're gone they're gone I know you
guys in San Diego I want the merge you
know where's it at when we hit 50k
dropping that first drop I know
everyone's like yo where's our merch at
did he just say that hold on so I'm only
dropping a limited amount and once
they're gone they're gone I know you
guys in San Diego I want the merge you
know where's it at so we hit 50k
dropping that first drop so yeah in that
note let's get to the video I'll see you
guys at the end oh yeah
what happened no I'm asking you to
please not record in our building
this is private property I'm asking you
to please not record
great
you're always doing the not talking
prank right now
also probably it's not like he didn't
actually know what to say yeah he tried
to play it off like a break
yo you guys want to go prank minimum
wage workers right now
sick oh [__]
all right thank you so this kid was shot
and uh
this one could be fun okay this one's
fun these videos make me laugh very hard
there you go
booby bracelet
this is his merch yes sir what the
[__] a booby bracelet I'm more
concerned with the two thousand dollar
care package that's out of stock
what's up booby oh oh I see I heart
classified boobies because he wrote
boobies on it do you remember I think it
was like 2010 there were those rubber
wristbands I said I heart boobies for
breast cancer
that's a play on that okay
very cool except not for a good cause
this one's not for chairs this is a
support misogyny yeah yeah this one is
foreign
uh 2 45. you guys want little Tay
boyfriend ick
or more elves from alpha do I I have
heard this boyfriend X stuff is funny
let's go oh miss Olive over here vouch
for it
all right Olivia there's a lot funny if
it's not funny
we're coming for you all right well I I
mean
it's funny
we can talk about if it's an
egg guys okay okay girlfriend began
recording and uploading tics of their
boyfriend participating in activities
that gave them the ick now from my
understanding that that's a great insult
yeah that's like all of a sudden like
I've heard it described as like
once you see it it's done the
relationship's over yeah or like you
started dating someone and then you know
is that accurate
um if the ick is really horrible yeah
sometimes you can't come back from it
sometimes yeah sometimes Little X will
culminate together to create one big ick
and then we're done some are crazy I
read like it's the way he holds the
steering wheel it's very specific and
you need to watch these videos
holds the steering wheel I got a mad ick
and I had to call it off
I saw I saw him trip and fall once and
it gave me the ick
those are those are Fringe ones but I've
read those the these these icks give me
the uh yeah true
it's Reverse Racism
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
they're like little slippers
[Music]
I get a bit of an ick but it's I mean
like it's sweet
it's a funnier experience right she's
like this is kind of funny no none of
these are actually serious I gotcha all
right riding a bike let's let's measure
this one
[Music]
the way he's riding the bike
I see it
it's the way he's like twisting his head
yeah the rock he's so so jolly I gotta
see it again I think it's just short Rod
no he's he's working his hips dude if he
stops he's gonna be on his tippy toes
it's the the bike is too big for him
yeah
I know enough
that's pretty funny honestly
he's just hanging out with his girl
trying to go on a bike ride and here she
is recording is beautiful look at his
little features his beautiful flips his
hips swaying his bike waddling having
such a good time it seems like taking in
the sights of the city but that's what
it is it's a nick
learning how to ride a horse
[Applause]
see I knew echo's boyfriend trying to
ride a horse
[Music]
okay Rhino horse is difficult though
that's pretty funny you know what I mean
why is he standing like that just sit I
know why he's standing like that because
it hurts his ball Crusher dude yeah
[Music]
man that's a hell of an arch though
yeah
I mean it's funny but this one seems a
little extreme because like
learning to ride a horse is like not
something you do every day like if
that's the first time you got to give a
little Grace right that's a Nick it's
still icky he leaves and never explains
why
like if he just always rode the horse
like that no she's gonna flee the ring
this is fun never see him again yeah
this shit's funny
so much fun that's like a cartoon
character he's just too tall bro what is
this cartoon [__]
that's hilarious
that's funny that is very funny that's
your man's you better take it all good
and bad you take it all
giant toddler that is [__] hilarious
I mean how about how would he stand that
didn't look silly I wonder no you're
right it's just there's nothing he can
do you just don't you just don't use
that thing you could bend down you just
gotta quit I think the movie's straight
legs bent back has to be you can't bend
the leg there's got to be a way to do
this more gracefully I think it's also
the hand placement too let's do it right
he double pissed it right the ham play
for stability what is he looking at dude
that's funny she left and never talked
to him again he came back from the
the uh telescope and he never saw his
girlfriend again
walking in water he just sees her
through the thing
walking away it's like wait a minute
water water heck
everybody watch out we have a water ick
careful in the water man is this lazy
river
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's pretty funny
although
let me see that again
that's pretty it's pretty I mean
that one's seen but you're just having
fun in the Lazy River
so I'll tell you I'll tell you whoever
was recording that video they were doing
the exact same thing to keep up with him
no they were scissor kicking I don't
know they were they have more days
seemed pretty steady you can scissor
kicks steadily I don't know
um holding up that phone
okay
[Music]
let's see trampoline oh
careful on the trampoline man
[Music]
[Laughter]
[__] I didn't even describe what they're
doing it's like
again yeah it's so silly
[Music]
[Laughter]
ran there and back for fun very nice
very good what careful on the trampoline
man
you know what's funny it's like fresh
and fit we'll watch this unironically
and being like you see make can exist in
a society without a woman get judging us
we can never open our emotions or show
who we really are every time I go to a
trampoline place I run just like that
just like that that's why I stopped
going to trampoline places I love
trampoline places
Sky Zone is my [__]
yo I used to love
[Music]
dude did you guys see that clip of Myron
recently where he's like I never had a
relationship in high school or college
and that's why yeah I swear he was like
in one of his rants
I did not see that that's delicious this
man never had a relationship through
college I sent it like 4am like well let
me see I feel like
I feel like if people knew that
well I'm glad he's just doing a podcast
and not killing people yeah
because that's like you know ultimate
gentleman [__]
uh
uh see
new ick unlocked
well the Bears got no space this is not
fair that's not fair who's sitting like
that in the front just silly what the
hell man pull you know what are you
doing he's at least listen he's squished
in there and he's not complaining yeah
we can cut on some slack his thighs are
[__] huge so I get that maybe like I
have those big ass juicy thighs too and
they're big boy I'm with you man they're
just big yeah
but that's not his fault either he's
being he's being a good dude he's
chilling dude taking it like a champ
like Jeff love you disagree with that
one yeah this one is way off unfair way
off that's fine not fair
that actually gives me the opposite of
the ick yeah that's the hottest video
ever I like them yeah
it's Key Lift ick
[Music]
there it is
[Laughter]
fun let me see that again what even
happened there
[Music]
what the [__]
I don't I mean okay I'm right
at least you can take your man's skiing
good luck getting me out of the house I
don't leave the house because I'm afraid
I'm gonna get I'm gonna you're gonna get
hit me and do an egg yep I stay indoors
at all times that's how hard it is being
a man in today's society
yo find me that clip baby I'm looking
for it
wow that explains a lot
that explains a lot how I mean damn bro
that's sad
hello look at him he's got a drawer full
of Plan B he's such a player he's
killing it killing it on YouTube oh wait
no you got demonetized oh right he's uh
killing it on Rumble oh wait he only got
10 000 views no [__] would have taken
me I'm kidding I don't know you see this
uh
Super Chat that lovescent 50 from chance
Covington uh no did you guys see the
lawyer who sued Alex Jones is suing Elon
Musk and not saying the majority report
they announced it on the majority part
that's a cool exclusive so wait who's
the guy I think they just they're just
saying they heard about it on majority
report today so the guy the lawyer who
represented the families is that what
that means yeah here I just pulled it up
Elon sued for libel by man falsely
identified in Neo-Nazi brawl okay
here let me pull it up so you can just
Elon Musk we're gonna learn about this
together right now yeah it was from
today
yeah falsely accused oh have you been
involved in a brawl between the proud
boys and a rival extremist group in
Oregon is suing Elon Musk accusing musk
of libel by amplifying social media
posts that mistakenly identified the man
this is interesting
retweeting or reposting must a pattern
of making Reckless false statements with
impunity and that is post trigger to
wave of harassment and threats not wrong
unless you seeks a million dollars and
damages a jury trial in Travis County
Texas where the lawsuit filed where musk
has a residence the fight broke out in
on Pride night in Portland June video of
the incident went viral online the next
day according to the lawsuit the lawsuit
said that Ben Brody was first accused of
being a member of Rose City never
incorrectly identified as a white
supremacist group Patriot front
this year known for ship posting
internet slang for deliberately posting
the social media with the intention of
provoking or upsetting people
huh
go on
I'm trying to see what here Musk
yeah it's right there once responded
here is it still up still up
okay oh it's like so oh man so they like
tried to like dox this guy and they have
the wrong person which let me see what
Matt Walsh said remember when they
called us go let's roll
remember when they called us conspiracy
theories for saying the feds were
planting fake Nazis at rallies so then
they show his face this is Matt Walsh
click that this is not Matt Walsh oh
Matt Wallace okay yeah who knows that
show The Leftovers there's a lot of
eights in their name though I notice
um
so Ben Brody is a fourth year political
science major blah blah blah after
graduation he plans to work for the
government C so they they're saying hey
this guy
is this guy and look he says he wants to
work for the government the problem is
this is not this person believe it
they're wrong person on the bottom left
this is the person who's suing Elon now
because Elon
showed his picture and his does this
have his name yeah oh that's crazy yeah
and so they misidentified this guy as
this guy this guy has nothing to do with
it that is interesting I mean he should
be definitely suing Matt Wallace I doubt
he has money though but now it is an
interesting question is so Elon
responded with always remove their masks
right
so I guess they're just saying because
he Amplified it it's almost like he's
encouraging them being like let's let's
take the mask off and find out who he is
right could be interpreted that way
after users pointed out that Brody was
not the man in vital video
winning the suit
nobody erased it
oh they're saying he did this after
people had already debunked this and
they us they never corrected or removed
it yeah I mean the Tweet still UPS
that's important
this has almost 80 or 73 000 wow that's
horrible and he has like 54 000 here
that's super [__] up
oh yeah yeah
good for you man get paid
1 million is not enough
you know what I mean
most personal endorsement of the false
accus it could go down must uh throw
some of the false accusation against Ben
reverberated across the internet
transforming the accusations from
Anonymous rumors to gospel Truth for
many individuals and causing others to
use must endorsement to justify their
desire to harass Ben and his family
man [__] Elon Musk
how has he not deleted it how is this
still up
like this is just an incorrect docs it's
just up with tons of likes on Twitter
he got paid to post it that's insane he
got paid to post it
I don't know if it was open then but
he got ten thousand dollars for that
oh here so this was another one where
same thing
and I guess this one is deleted
but his reply is still up looks like one
is in college
who wants to join the government and
another is maybe an antifa member
but nonetheless probably still a false
flag situation
boy you are a [__] lunatic
I'm an [__]
um
he really is a psycho
here's my run talking about how he he
didn't have a girlfriend his whole
[__] life
girlfriend bam you know what and I
listen I feel bad for for people that
you know have problems like that and the
only reason I'm making fun of you is
because you're turned into such a
misogynistic freak Show and uh it
explains why you're so damaged and why
you hate women when really
I'm sure it's all your fault
you know this right now
this video has music in it we need to
check it before we watch it
uh damn
I really want to watch it you got no
girls top comment
Bingo scene being single means being
focused Amen brother
facts we waste so much of our youth
chasing cat imagine if you just worked
on yourself for a few years then got a
cat later
yeah I mean he's coping hard yo I never
had a girlfriend in high school college
or any other time I'm focused on myself
I mean that's fine if that's what you
want to do it but
um clearly
clearly it was not by choice
here's a comment in Myron's case oh hell
no it's very telling that Myron has
never had a serious girlfriend he still
hasn't to this day by the way nor has he
ever been in love pretty sad for a man
in his 30s his views will change
dramatically when this happens to him
yeah yeah and I think it ever does
I mean
he's going to need like a special
special woman
to impact any change on him Halo
all right how long are we going now
three hours
Short episode
showed up today
Nobody Does it Like Us
three [__] hours
[Music]
all right well um let's see here
Wednesday we'll be back uh for members
I'll be there on Tuesdays you guys know
the drill
uh one o'clock let me check my calendar
just to make sure I don't have anything
I'm pretty sure
that'll work
yeah we're good for tomorrow at one and
then anything else we want to talk about
coming up later this week
well like you said we're gonna
theoretically do this members drive on
Friday that'll be really fun episode
it's gonna be really fun the uh details
uh we're gonna have to iron out tomorrow
but we have the ideas there's gonna be
lots lots of drinking lots of uh
laughter it'll be a fun app yeah it's
gonna be a bonus
um and what else what else is going on
this week
three
uh we have some fun guests coming up
later this month got a few lined up
actually go ahead uh Curtis Connor is
coming back
uh next week actually oh that's fun
let's go and uh later this month uh
Pokemon is gonna be joining us there you
go you know what she told me she said
now that Love's here I want to come to
the show it's very kind very nice very
excited to meet her she hasn't forgot
about you bro very nice uh yeah I mean
and uh and we have a couple other fun
ones that aren't locked yet but we're
working on so
that's happening yeah that's happening
folks little Tay uh do you guys really
want does anyone care about little Tay I
don't know no that's like a [__]
or one if you're gonna do it maybe if
you guys care I can do it on Wednesday I
don't know
the whole little taste thing never
really interested me
what's the story uh somebody said she
was dead she's not no they're they're a
lot more in development okay
also she's very impressive is that
inaccurate what I just say really well
that's the beginning of it but now she's
gotten more so much detailing her abuse
here's one short video Let's watch it
so how old is she now 16. we were
starting but it's like 10 minutes I just
want to watch a second of it Dan
we're driving start five years ago
I'm famous
and my abusive absentee father who had
not been in my life for years up till
that point
decided to come back into my life to
take control over my career and my money
that's why I Disappeared he started a
court case
he started a court case that sounds
awful yeah it's really I'm not ready to
get into that 10 minute long video it
sounds like a lot
yeah
it'll take time alrighty listen guys
thanks for being here
had fun today with you guys nice to see
you
beautiful weather
uh see members tomorrow
and um normal time you said right one
o'clock yeah perfect have a great week
guys and we'll be seeing you uh tomorrow
or the next day but we're always here is
the H3 podcast no one does it like us
we're live all the [__] time for free
except see you next Tuesday but that
doesn't count
[Music]
age three yeah